Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Zeit an diesem Ort heißt, es ist Chaosradio. Letzter Nachsagemonat, 30. Juni. Herzlich willkommen und zu Gast wie immer jemand hier bei Fritz, jemand vom Chaos Computer Club. Oh Gott, das werde ich bestimmt gleich gesteinigt von den Unmengen Leuten, die im IRC Chat zu dieser Sendung rum sitzen. Da könnt ihr auch gerne mitmachen. Ist auf freenote.net der Channel Chaos Radio. Zu Gast auf jeden Fall hier vom Chaos Computer Club, Andreas Bogk. Mitgebracht außerdem Niels Kobschätzki.
Schön genannt.
Hallo. Seines Zeichens Volkswirtschaftswissenschaftler. Ist das richtig?
Volkswirt.
Volkswirt. Einfach nur Volkswirt. Wozu braucht der Chaos Computer Club einen Volkswirt in einer Sendung? Herr Bogk, mögen Sie das vielleicht kurz erklären?
Ja, die heutige Sendung dreht sich um Geld. Digitales Geld, die Bitcoin hat ja eine große Welle erzeugt. Sicherlich hat jeder schon mal gehört. Wir haben das auch schon mehrfach diskutiert. Jedes Mal kommt dann die Frage, wie ist das denn nun mit der Geldmenge und der Steuerung? Ist das jetzt gut oder schlecht? Was gibt es da für Philosophien? Wo kommt das Geld überhaupt her? Und weil wir dann alle immer da sitzen und sagen so Pfff, ja... Dachten wir, wir probieren es mal mit jemandem, der sich auskennt.
Der sich auskennen muss quasi, genau. Du bist noch nicht ganz fertig studiert, aber auf dem besten Weg dahin, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe.
Ja, so Volkswirtschaftslehre bin ich fertig. Der andere Teil noch nicht ganz.
Ah, der andere Teil, okay. Das ist natürlich unwichtig in diesem Zusammenhang. Um Bitcoins geht es. Oder Bitcoin, das ist die Streitfrage, wo ihr zum Beispiel auch anrufen könnt. 0331 70 97 110. Gibt es überhaupt eine Mehrzahl von Bitcoin? Mit einem S am Ende oder nicht? Das können wir heute noch abstimmen. Ich bin in Ansicht Ja. Es gibt auch andere Leute, die sagen Nein. Die wichtigere Frage ist aber, was sind Bitcoin? Oder was ist ein Bitcoin? Bitcoins überhaupt, wo kommen die her? Was machen die? Wieso ist das eine Zahlweise im Netz? Ansatzpunkt ist, dass gesagt wurde, also Leute, wir haben das Internet und wir brauchen irgendwie was, das wir mal bezahlen können, was nicht den Standardweg geht. Der Standardweg ist ja, entweder ich habe eine Kreditkarte oder ich habe ein wie auch immer geartetes Bezahlsystem, wo ich mich aber einloggen muss mit einem Account und dann irgendwie da Geld hinkriegen und dann funktioniert das nur über bestimmte Anbieter. Zum Beispiel die Online-Stores von den ganzen Konsolenherstellern sind da irgendwie schöne Beispiele für. Die Idee ist sozusagen, es müsste doch sowas geben wie Bargeld. Also so einfach austauschbar, kleinste Beträge machbar, ohne dass irgendwie über mehr Gebühren anfallen. Möglicherweise sogar gleich noch anonym. All das wäre doch total geil. Und der Bitcoin ist zumindest angetreten mit dem Versprechen, also dem Heilsversprechen könnte man fast schon sagen, all diese Dinge möglicherweise möglich zu machen. Aber ob das klappt, wissen wir nicht. Wir müssen erstmal klären, wie es funktioniert. Herr Bogk, wie entsteht denn dein Bitcoin?
Magisch aus der Luft. Geld entstehen ist auch ein spannendes Thema. Das müssen wir später noch mal diskutieren. Aber bleiben wir erstmal bei den Bitcoins. Bitcoin, der Name ist ein bisschen irreführend, weil man denkt bei Bitcoin an sowas wie Münzen und digitale Münzen, also irgendwelche Bithaufen, die einen Wert repräsentieren, die man vom einen zum anderen schieben kann.
Das war meine spontane Assoziation. Es gibt so eine Art verschlüsseltes Dateiding, was sich möglicherweise auf CDs brennen kann. Und die CD ist dann meine neue Brieftasche.
Ja, funktioniert leider nicht ganz so. Weil jeder weiß, der sich schon mal ein bisschen länger im Internet rumgetrieben hat, gibt es genau gar nichts, was einen Bithaufen daran hindert, kopiert zu werden, sodass man zwei identische Bithaufen hat. Während man so eine echte Münze, also wenn man mal so ein klassisches Goldstück nimmt, es ist relativ schwierig zu duplizieren. Da kann man nicht einfach zwei draus machen. Von Bits kann man immer zwei Haufen draus machen. Und jetzt haben viele schlaue Leute lange drüber nachgedacht. Eine der ersten Ansätze war DigiCash Mitte der 90er. Muss man vielleicht nicht wirklich ausführlich erklären, aber diese ganzen tollen Ansätze, also Kryptografen haben ganze Konferenzen darüber veranstaltet, wie man versuchen kann, die Bithaufen dann doch nicht kopierbar zu machen, oder vielleicht doch und so weiter und so fort. Dann kam PayPal und da hat das alles anders funktioniert. Da schickt man einfach sein Geld mit der Kreditkarte hin und loggt sich auf der Webseite ein.
Es wurde aber keine wirkliche Lösung für dieses Problem gefunden. Es gibt keine Möglichkeit, einen Bithaufen unkopierbar zu machen, auch wenn sich viele Wissenschaftler getroffen haben.
Es gibt keine Möglichkeit, einen Bithaufen unkopierbar zu machen. Das ist ein grundlegendes Prinzip. Das merken auch immer wieder die Leute, die Filme und Musik rausgeben oder Computerspiele. Das geht einfach nicht. Wissenschaftlicher ausgedrückt ist das Problem des Double Spending. Man kann dasselbe digitale Geld zweimal ausgeben. Alle Verfahren, die es so gibt, setzen sich damit auseinander, wie man verhindert, dass dasselbe Geld zweimal ausgegeben wird. Ein möglicher Ansatz, wenn man sich so vorstellen kann, ist, es gibt die zentrale Instanz, die zentrale Internetweltbank. Jeder, der bezahlen will, geht zum Händler und gibt ihm seinen Bithaufen. Der Händler geht dann mit dem Bithaufen zur zentralen Internetweltbank und sagt irgendwie, wurde diese Münze schon mal ausgegeben, ja oder nein. Und wenn die Weltbank dann sagt nein, dann hat die Bezahlung funktioniert. Wenn die Weltbank sagt ja, dann hat die Bezahlung nicht funktioniert. Und der Ansatz bei Bitcoin ist mehr oder weniger der Versuch...
Warte, warte, warte, ich muss dich gleich nochmal reinhaken. Gute Idee, warum machen wir es nicht so?
Weil dann gibt es die zentrale Internetbank.
Und die ist sozusagen persönlich vertrauenswürdig.
Genau, also das gibt sozusagen eine Denkschule. Jetzt sind wir schon irgendwie bei den philosophischen Grundlagen. Es gibt die Anarchisten, es gibt die Krypto-Anarchisten, die in den letzten 20 Jahren viel Forschung im Internet gemacht haben, die der Meinung sind, zentral ist schlecht, dezentral ist besser. Und Bitcoin ist mehr oder weniger der Versuch, ein Geldsystem zu schaffen, das ohne zentrale Instanz auskommt.
Trotzdem soll aber dieser Ansatz verfolgt werden, dass wenn ein Bezahlvorgang an den Start kommt, dass dann man irgendwo fragen kann, ist dieses Geld schon ausgegeben worden. Der Ansatz ist dann noch erhalten?
Genau, den muss man, weil Bitze lassen sich kopieren. Das ist eine grundlegende Einsicht.
Und wer macht das dann? Also wer klärt das?
Das ist das Spannende dabei. Das macht jeder. Es gibt sozusagen nicht mehr die Zentralbank, sondern es gibt eine Peer-to-Peer-Zentralbank. Jeder ist die Zentralbank gleichzeitig.
Du siehst meine hochgezogenen Augenbrauen, mein fragende Gesichtsausdruck. Wie soll das funktionieren?
Technisch gesehen funktioniert das so, dass es erstmal gar keine Coins gibt, sondern alles, was es gibt, ist ein Buchhaltungssystem, in dem es Konten gibt. Und man kann von einem einen Konto auf das andere Konto Geld überweisen. Das funktioniert so, dass jedem Konto eine Identität zugeordnet ist, eine Adresse. Und ein geheimer Schlüssel, mit dem man Überweisungen unterschreiben kann. Also muss man sich echt vorstellen, wie bei der Bank Überweisungsträger. Man hat seine Quellkontonummer und seine Zielkontonummer. Und da schreibt man drunter. Nur halt digital mit Standard. Kryptographischen Verfahren mit asymmetrischen Schlüsseln.
Es ist natürlich nur ganz grob gefragt. Kann ich mir das vorstellen wie PGP-Verschlüsselung bei E-Mail? Oder ist das was ganz ganz anderes?
Das ist ungefähr genau dasselbe. Ungefähr genauso funktioniert das. Und jetzt hängen alle Leute, die einen solchen Bitcoin-Client haben, die also Bitcoin-Geld haben, in einer großen Peer-to-Peer-Wolke. Genauso wie das mit dem BitTorrent funktioniert in der großen Wolke. Redet jeder mit seinen Nachbarn. Und wenn ich jetzt Geld überweise, dann schicke ich an alle meine Nachbarn quasi eine Kopie dieses Überweisungsformulars mit meiner Unterschrift drauf. Und alle Clients haben eine ewige Liste, wo sie sich merken, welche Transaktionen passiert sind und welche nicht. Also eigentlich ein Buchhaltungssystem, wo jeder alle Überweisungen sieht, mehr oder weniger.
Also das ist eigentlich so ein Prinzip, könnte man es vergleichen mit, ich nehme einen Zettel, schreibe darauf in meiner unfälschbaren Handschrift, ich gebe dir einen Bitcoin, überreiche dir den und lasse irgendwie 40.000 Leute zugucken.
Genau, nämlich jeder, der auch Bitcoin hat, der kriegt eine Kopie von dem Zettel, damit jeder weiß, dass du mir gerade Geld gegeben hast. Damit ich weiter Geld geben kann.
Jetzt könnte ich ja aber trotzdem hingehen und sagen, ich muss ja nur genug Leute davon überzeugen, dass es Schnickschnack ist und die bestätigen wir das trotzdem.
Und dann habe ich ja doch wieder die Bits kopiert. Das ist richtig. Und an der Stelle kommt sozusagen die geniale Erfindung, die das System möglich macht. Und zwar funktioniert das so, dass alle 10 Minuten etwa im Schnitt quasi vom gesamten Netz ein Zeitstempel errechnet wird, wo alle bisher aufgelaufenen Transaktionen zusammengefasst werden. Eine Unterschrift drunter, sodass keine Transaktionen entfernt oder hinzugefügt werden können. Und die Überlegung ist jetzt, diese Unterschrift alle 10 Minuten unter die nächsten Transaktionen, Blogs werden die genannt, also die Unterschrift oder den nächsten Blog, die wird so schwierig gemacht, dass das ganze Netz, also alle Leute, die da mit drin hängen, ganz viel rechnen müssen, um diese Unterschrift zu finden. Und wenn jemand eine Transaktion fälschen will, muss er mehr Rechenleistung als der Rest des Netzes aufbringen. Das ist so die zentrale Idee.
Aber wenn ich es richtig verstehe, ist es doch so, so ein Blog ist ja dann erst abgeschlossen, wenn diese 10 Minuten rum sind.
Das kommt drauf an, das variiert auch ein bisschen das nächste Mal, wenn jemand eine Unterschrift gefunden hat. Also es wird sozusagen künstlich schwierig gemacht, die Unterschrift für den Blog zu erzeugen. Und alle rechnen wie wild rum. Und wenn mal wieder jemand eine Lösung gefunden hat, dann wird der nächste Blog erzeugt, wird sozusagen das nächste Stückchen des ewigen Logfiles weitergeschrieben.
Aber wenn ich es richtig verstehe, ist es doch so, dass dann, wenn die nächste Unterschrift quasi gefunden wurde, dann ist ein Blog von Transaktionen in der Vergangenheit dann festgelegt.
Genau.
Aber bis dahin ist er ja noch änderbar.
Bis dahin ist er noch änderbar. Also es dauert immer so ein bisschen, bis die Transaktion wirklich ankommt und jeder das glauben kann, weil es ausreichend sozusagen verewigt ist.
Aber es gibt keine Möglichkeit, sozusagen im laufenden Blog Dinge zu fälschen.
Na ja, du könntest, brauchst du die Unterschrift, um Transaktionen zu erzeugen. Und wenn du Geld zweimal ausgeben willst, dann musst du die Unterschrift ja wieder verschwinden lassen. Also sozusagen einmal überwiesenes Geld. Da gibt es deine Überweisungsträger dazu. Wenn ich jetzt zweimal Geld ausgeben will, dann darf diese erste Überweisung nicht mehr im ewigen Lockfall auftauchen. Solange die Unterschrift noch nicht da ist, habe ich als Empfänger des Geldes keine Garantie dafür, dass es auch wirklich ankommt, dass es wirklich existiert ist.
Ah, okay, also man kann es jetzt so vorstellen, es gibt diesen Überweisungsvorgang, aber der gilt erst als getätigt, wenn sozusagen diese nächste Unterschrift, also wenn dieser Überweisungsvorgang in so einem Block drin ist, der auch unterschrieben wurde.
Genau.
Ah, verstehe. Wenn man sich jetzt so ein Bitclient installiert, dann sieht man das, wenn man so Überweisungen tätigt. Also das ist so ein Programm, vielleicht für alle Leute, die das noch gar nicht ausprobiert haben selber, weil sie das nur gehört haben. Das ist ein ganz einfaches Programm, das kann man sich ganz einfach runterladen und starten und das funktioniert dann auch sofort. Man kriegt dann so eine kryptische Adresse. Das ist sozusagen die eine Bitcoin-Adresse, die man hat. Da kann man sich beliebig viele von generieren. Und wenn man da mit so einer Überweisung tätig, dann erscheint die Anzahl der Confirmations, also der Leute, die das gesehen haben anscheinend.
Die Anzahl der Blogs, die nachträglich, also seit deiner Überweisung, unterschrieben wurden. Weil jeder Blog enthält sozusagen die Unterschrift für den Blog davor mit. Die sind aneinandergehängt wie so eine Kette.
Gibt es da eine bestimmte Anzahl, wo man sagt, jetzt wird es vertrauenswürdiger und jetzt nicht?
Ja, das kommt immer darauf an, wie viel Geld man da nimmt. Wenn es irgendwie kleine Beträge gibt, dann ist die erste in der Regel ausreichend, weil niemand die Rechenleistung dafür aufbringt. Wenn es größere Beträge gibt, dann wartet man vielleicht schon bei fünf bis sechs Blogs.
Das ist tatsächlich so, dass die Rechenleistung so viel Energie oder was in Anspruch nimmt, dass es nicht lohnt, für kleine Beträge das anzuwerfen?
Ja, für kleine Beträge lohnt sich das nicht. Also es geht dann eher drum, große Beträge. Also man muss sich überlegen, da hängen Zehntausende von Rechnern drin und man muss mehr Rechenleistung aufwenden, um eine Transaktion zu fälschen. Das tut man nicht für Zehntbeträge.
Ok, jetzt haben wir schon die ersten Anrufer. Wollen wir gleich mal welche hineinnehmen? Da ist zum Beispiel der Florian, der aus Recklinghausen anruft und 20 Jahre alt ist. Hallo Florian.
Hi, Florian hier. Und zwar mir ist das alles...
Ok, ganz langsam. Hier steht, dass du den Sinn der Bitcoins nicht verstehst.
Also mein Verständnis hört darauf, indem sich schon andere Systeme etabliert haben. Also ich hab schon grad von Paypal gehört. Und, also, das kenn ich schon lange. Und damit, das benutze ich auch. Das geht ja auch über Amerika, aber China, da gibt's ja auch beim Wechsel der Währung eigentlich keine Probleme. Und ich sag mal jetzt, aber da ist mir noch was weiteres noch zu eingefallen. Und zwar sind wir jetzt in der Zeit, wo die Marktwirtschaft sehr stark ist, in der Zeit von Google, Facebook und wo die alle am Datensammeln sind, ohne uns irgendwie sowas mal zu erzählen. Und wenn da jetzt irgendein Shop sagt, ja, okay, wir nehmen jetzt diese Bitcoins mal an, dann kann er da ja kaum Marktforschung mit treiben. Also deswegen glaube ich ehrlich gesagt nicht, dass sich das irgendwann durchsetzen wird. Die würden dann, wenn überhaupt, dann noch zu PayPal zugreifen, weil das schon viel ausgereifter ist. Und dann kann auch PayPal dann weiter auf Marktforschung betreiben.
Okay, also ich nehme dem, also ich habe es nicht ganz verstanden, aber ich nehme mit dem zumindest eine einzelne Frage und das ist die der praktischen Relevanz. Also es gibt Bezahlsysteme im Netz, die einfach funktionieren und Bitcoin ist halt sozusagen noch etwas sperriges. Warum interessieren sich Leute praktisch dafür? Also ich meine als theoretisches Konzept, okay, aber was ist der praktische Nutzen von Bitcoins?
Also eins der Probleme, das per Design adressiert werden soll und das tatsächlich auch Leute betrifft, ist, dass bei Paypal halt die zentrale Instanz Paypal existiert, die mehr oder weniger nach Gutdünken entscheiden kann, mit wem sie Geschäfte macht und wem nicht. Also wenn man zum Beispiel sich nackig ausziehen und die Bilder dann im Internet verkaufen möchte, dann geht das nicht bei Paypal.
Du bist Leute, die sowas tun?
Hab ich gehört, ja. Und ja auch die Spenden für Wikileaks zum Beispiel wurden von Paypal blockiert. Es gab andere Fälle, wo Paypal einfach gesagt hat Nö, ihr kriegt das Geld jetzt nicht wieder, weil eure Existenz, die glaube ich euch nicht. Also diese Abhängigkeit von einem zentralen Dienstleister, das ist das, was Bitcoin adressieren soll. Das ist tatsächlich auch ein Problem da draußen.
Also es geht darum, ein System zu schaffen, wo niemand verbieten kann, irgendwas damit zu bezahlen. Sondern diese Bargeldidee steckt auch dahinter.
Genau.
Also wenn ich es dir gebe, dann ist es halt sozusagen okay. Gut, jetzt haben wir noch einen Florian dran. Und ich vermute, dass der auch nicht ganz mit dem Thema zu tun hat. Wir hören trotzdem kurz rein. Florian aus Rundschönehausen, hallo.
Hallöchen.
Hier steht was von Facebook. Das hat jetzt aber gar nichts mit Bitcoins zu tun.
Naja, doch mehr oder weniger. Und zwar geht es darum. Also ich wollte bei Facebook Bitcoins aufladen. Nur leider ist das Problem, also nicht nur auf Facebook, sondern auf vielen anderen Seiten, dass man nicht nur Paypal haben kann, sondern nur mit Kreditkarte diese Bitcoins aufladen kann. Und das ist mein Problem. Weil auf Seiten wie Dove's Friend Finder und Facebook kann ich nur per Kreditkarte aufladen. Und ich hab keine Kreditkarte, ich möchte mir auch keine Kreditkarte holen, weil einfach die Kosten und die Kosten, die darauf anfallen, viel zu hoch sind. Und ich möchte da nicht in so eine Schuldenfalle tappen. Und ich wollte mal fragen, wie kann man das umgehen und wirklich ohne eine Kreditkarte diese Bitcoins aufladen?
Also mir wäre neu, dass es per Facebook funktioniert. Das ist interessant. Es gibt verschiedene Märkte, wo man Bitcoins kaufen kann. Zum Beispiel bitmarket.eu ist ein Europäischer, der auch Banküberweisungen innerhalb Deutschlands annimmt. Also die Seite selber nicht, sondern die vermittelt sozusagen jemanden, der ein Bitcoins verkauft und da Paypal annimmt oder Banküberweisungen annimmt oder SEPA oder Zwift. Also man braucht keine Kreditkarte dafür.
Ich möchte mal kurz fragen, Florian, geht es dir wirklich um Bitcoins oder geht es dir um Facebook Credits?
Naja, das sind ja auch diese Online-Punkte. Das ist doch eigentlich ein und dasselbe, oder?
Nein, nein, nein. Ein ganz wichtiges Missverständnis müssen wir an dieser Stelle klären. Ich dachte, es sei schon klar geworden. Bitcoins ist tatsächlich ein ganz bestimmtes Zahlungsmittel. Wir reden heute nicht über die allgemeine virtuelle Währung, sondern über einen ganz bestimmten Ansatz, nämlich den der Bitcoins. Und Facebook Credits haben damit überhaupt nichts zu tun. Trotzdem, die Frage, die sich noch daraus ergibt, die man vielleicht nochmal beantworten könnte, ist, warum ist eine Kreditkarte eigentlich so ein beliebtes Zahlungsmittel? Könnt ihr das beantworten? Also warum ist eine Kreditkarte so allgegenwärtig im Netz und alles andere eher schwierig?
Also ich denke mal, es liegt auch mit der Beliebtheit der Kreditkarte in den USA zusammen. Und ein Großteil der Dienste ist in den USA einfach mal entstanden. Und Kreditkartenunternehmen sind einfach mal schon vertrauenswürdige Gegenseiten, um Zahlungen abzuhandeln. Also in Deutschland gibt es jetzt Paypal als Anbieter, der da beliebt ist. Aber in den USA sind es halt die Kreditkartenunternehmen und die sind um einiges weiter verbreitet als alles andere, was man auch merkt, dass es dort halt nicht Überweisungen oder Einzugsverfahren so richtig gibt, sondern halt wirklich alles über Kreditkarte gemacht wird.
Es liegt also tatsächlich daran, dass wenn ich als Händler jetzt losgehe und ein Betalungssystem an den Start bringen will, dann ist eine Kreditkarten Company einfach sozusagen ein vertrauenswürdiger Handelspartner für mich. Der die Risiken animiert, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie übers Netz zu Geld kommen will.
Ja genau, die Kreditkartenunternehmen haben ja auch Betrugsschutz eingebaut und Ähnliches.
Die auch ganz schön teuer ist. Die Tatsache, dass man eigentlich bloß diese 15 Zeichen braucht und noch so ein CVV-Code, um in der Kreditkarte einzukaufen, führt zu relativ hohen Missbrauchsquoten. Und diese 3% Gebühren, die man da zahlt, da geht bestimmt ein % für Fraud Detection und Fraud Prevention und ist mal wieder was passiert, muss man den Kunden sein Geld zurückzahlen drauf.
Gibt es denn so irgendwie gängige Wege, also nicht so eine Kreditkarte zu haben? Also was ich jetzt gerade dachte, es gibt ja Prepaid Kreditkarten, ist das so ein Weg, um da so ein bisschen zu umgehen oder?
Ja und man kann anonyme Prepaid Kreditkarten mit Bitcoin kaufen.
Ja ok, aber dann schieße ich wieder vor der Frage, wo kriege ich denn den Bitcoin her, mit dem ich diese anonyme Prepaid Kreditkarte bezahle?
Ja, na wie gesagt, man muss einfach jemanden finden, der irgendwelche verkauft. Das geht in beliebigen Medien. Es gibt IRC-Channels, es gibt Webseiten. Oder man kann sie meinen, das hat man glaube ich noch nicht erwähnt. Die, wir hatten ja das mit den Blogs, alle 10 Minuten kommt ein Blog dazu zur ewigen Liste, es wird eine Unterschrift erstellt. Und derjenige, der, ne andersrum, dafür muss viel Rechenzeit aufgewendet werden, um diese Blogs zu erzeugen, um diese Unterschrift zu erzeugen. Und um die Leute zu motivieren, das zu tun, bekommt derjenige, der es schafft, diese Unterschrift zu generieren, also dieses schwierige Problem zu lösen, dafür 50 Bitcoin. Die werden einfach aus der Luft erzeugt, die hängen dann da dran, man kann sich jetzt sagen, als Belohnung nochmal 50 Bitcoin anheften.
Wait, what? Also ich mein, wir haben also ein Geldsystem. Und das heißt unter dem Geldsystem ist die Einheit jetzt ein Bitcoin. Lieber, wenn ich was mache, werden 50 neue erzeugt.
Ja, alle 10 Minuten von dem, der den Block unterschrieben hat.
Da hat man dann so eine totale Inflation. Da ist ja der Bitcoin einfach nichts wert, weil ich mir nicht mehr selber so ein Ding ausrechnen kann.
Na spannenderweise ist genau das Gegenteil der Fall, nämlich eine eingebaute Deflation. Und zwar verringert sich die Menge Bitcoin, die man bekommt für die Unterschrift regelmäßig. Und dass es eine Systemgrenze eingebaut ist, werden nicht mehr als 21 Millionen Bitcoin überhaupt erzeugt.
Okay, wir haben hier Einspruch von der Volkswirtseite.
Ja, also die Inflation ist eingebaut, aber die ist relativ langsam. Man muss sich halt auch die Nachfrage anschauen. Die eingebaute Deflation entsteht dadurch, dass die Maximalmenge an Bitcoin, die erzeugt werden können, also das läuft grenzwertig an. Dadurch, dass aktuell immer nur 50 Bitcoin erzeugt werden. In ein paar Jahren werden immer nur 25 Bitcoin erzeugt. Und das wird immer weiter halbiert. Dadurch wird das Geldmengenwachstum immer langsamer. Und läuft dann grenzwertig bei 21 Millionen Bitcoins an. Und die Deflation liegt darin, dass Realwährungen wie jetzt Dollar oder Euro weiterhin weiteren Geldmengenwachstum haben. Und dadurch Bitcoin im Verhältnis immer mehr wert werden. Weil die halt nicht in der Geldmenge wachsen.
Also weil der Bitcoin selber ist begrenzt. Die 21 Millionen habt ihr gesagt. Man kann ja ausrechnen, wann das soweit sein müsste. Dass es quasi kein Bitcoin mehr gibt fürs Malen. Gibt es ein Datum?
Das müsste in 15 Jahren. Das sollte man am besten mal nachgucken.
Die Bitcoin-Kalypse?
Naja, man kann ja Bitcoin in acht Dezimalstellen teilen. Also das ist weitaus mehr als unsere hundertstel Einheiten.
Das fand ich ganz spannend. Das ist ja tatsächlich so, das wurde mir auch schon gesagt. Also Bitcoins kann man sozusagen 0, 0000001 Bitcoins ausgeben. Wenn ich versucht habe, eine Überweisung über diese Bitcoins zu machen, hieß es immer, dass die Geldmenge zu klein ist. Das kostet 0, 01 Transaktionskosten.
Da musst du dir neuen kleinen drunterladen. Die Mindesttransaktionskosten wurden neulich gesenkt.
Heißt? Was heißt neuen kleinen? Also einfach eine neue Version der Software?
Neue Softwareversion, ja.
Und dann muss man sozusagen, dann wird das immer wieder angepasst, oder wie?
Das wird gelinglich angepasst. Du konntest auch schon vorher einfach den Sourcecode ändern und deine Mindestgebühr senken oder nicht reintun. Man läuft dann immer Gefahr, wenn man keine Transaktionskosten... Also es ist freiwillig, man kann freiwillig an seine Überweisung eine Transaktionsgebühr ranhängen. Und derjenige, der den Block berechnet, bekommt die Transaktionsgebühren als zusätzlichen Bonus ausgezahlt. Und die Transaktionen gehen auch durch, wenn man da nichts dran hängt heutzutage. Und es ist aber absehbar, dass irgendwann, wenn die Anzahl Transaktionen größer wird, die mit Transaktionsgebühr dran bevorzugt werden, schneller durchgehen.
Ah, das ist aber nicht mehr neutral.
Nee, aber das kannst du bieten. Wer am meisten bietet, dessen Transaktion geht am schnellsten durch.
Verstehe, verstehe. Was mich ja noch interessiert ist, wer eigentlich dahinter steht. Ich wollte gerade fragen, ob jemand diese Transaktionskosten verdient, aber das ist anscheinend nicht der Fall, sonst kriegt jemand, der den Block ausrechnet. Aber steckt eigentlich jemand hinter diesem System? Also hat da irgendjemand was direkt von?
Na ja, die Leute, die es erfunden haben, waren natürlich auch die ersten, die beim Bitcoin-Mining angefangen haben, also Bitcoin generiert haben, und die haben jetzt schon durchaus 10.000 bis 100.000 Bitcoin rumzulegen. Und da haben sie verdient. Aber im aktuell laufenden System, da gibt es sozusagen nicht die zentrale Instanz, die davon profitiert, sondern jeder, der teilnimmt, kann da gleichermaßen von profitieren. Also wenn bei Mining was verdienen, oder eine Exchange-Seite aufmachen, oder keine Ahnung, Socken verkaufen.
Socken verkaufen. Dazu kommen wir, würde ich sagen, gleich. Also wir haben jetzt schon mal gehört, Mining, da werden wir gleich noch mal genauer drüber reden müssen. Also die Art und Weise, wie diese Unterschriften und diese Transaktionsblöcke generiert werden, die gleichzeitig auch wieder neue Bitcoins ins Spiel bringen und die Möglichkeiten, wie man sonst noch an Bitcoins rankommt, das scannen wir gleich.
Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Heute Chaosradio, zu Gast beim Chaosradio Andreas Bogk vom Chaos Computer Club.
Hallo.
Und Niels Kobschätzki, ein Volkswirt.
Und den brauchen wir heute, weil es heute um Bitcoins geht. Bitcoins sind eine virtuelle Währung. Das ist vielleicht falsch, eine digitale Währung. Ist die Währung eigentlich virtuell? Kann man das sagen? Eigentlich nicht oder doch?
Alle Währungen sind virtuell.
Also ich würde sie als virtuelle Währung bezeichnen und die anderen Währungen schon als Realwährung.
Okay, dazu kommen wir gleich. Sehr spannend. Hier wird es, glaube ich, gleich nochmal spannend. Kurz noch zusammengefasst, was wir in der ersten halben Stunde geklärt haben. Bitcoins sind also eine Währung, die dadurch entsteht, nicht, dass es irgendwo Geldstücke gibt, sondern dass sich viele Leute im Netz darauf einigen, dass bestimmte Transaktionen stattgefunden haben. Und um das sozusagen festzuhalten, diese Transaktionen für jeden verfolgbar zu machen, werden diese in sogenannten Blöcken codiert. Und man kann sie im Netz daran beteiligten, diese Blöcke sozusagen zu unterschreiben. Und jeder, der so eine Unterschrift ausrechnet, bekommt neue Bitcoins. Also ein System, das sich selber Geld generiert. Allerdings nur eine endliche Menge. 21 Millionen soll es insgesamt geben. Dann ist damit Schluss.
Wir hatten übrigens gerade im Chat einen Experten, der gemeint hat, es werden nie 21 Millionen werten, weil es sich ja asymptotisch annähert. Ist im Prinzip richtig. Aber da die Bitcoins ja keine beliebige Auflösung haben, sondern nur 8 Nachkommastellen, wird irgendwann ein Punkt erreicht sein, wo sie nicht mehr werden. Und das wird ungefähr im Jahr 2000, was war das, 2140, also wir haben noch ein bisschen Zeit, wird es dann 20.999.999,9769 Bitcoin geben.
Falls ihr dazu eine Frage habt, kann ich euch noch Folgendes empfehlen. 0331 70 97 110 So, jetzt hatten wir gerade schon, also die Frage, die ich jetzt eigentlich an Niels stellen wollte ist, wir haben ein System, das sozusagen darauf basiert, dass Leute gegenseitig unterschreiben, dass Transaktionen stattgefunden haben, wo der Wert also jetzt auf den ersten Blick völlig unklar ist. Du meinst jetzt gerade schon, Bitcoins, findest du, sind virtuell und anderes Geld ist real. Warum?
Sich wird anderes Geld als real bezeichnen, weil eine Institution, in dem Sinne ein Staat oder eine Zentralbank dahinter steht und das Geld, das ich in der Hand halte, die Verpflichtung gegenüber diesem Staat oder dieser Zentralbank ist, während ich bei Bitcoin eben keine Entität mehr dahinter stehen habe, sondern nur diese Datenbank, in dem halt überhaupt keine Verpflichtungen mehr da sind.
Ja, jetzt müssen wir ein bisschen spitzfindig werden. Also früher stand ja auf den Banknoten drauf, dass dem Überbringer eine bestimmte Menge Gold ausgezahlt wird. Ist ja mittlerweile abgeschafft, also Goldbackwährung gibt es nicht mehr. Also welche Verpflichtung steckt denn da dahinter, die der Staat eingegangen ist oder die Zentralbank, außer mir für meine bunten bedruckten Scheine, andere bunte bedruckte Scheine zu geben?
Naja, der Staat sagt ja schon, dass das Geld, dass das das Zahlungsmittel in seinem Land ist.
Also man kann seine Steuern da bezahlen, das macht es real?
Zum Beispiel.
Okay, weil ich bin der Meinung, dass auch anderes Geld eigentlich nur deswegen was wert ist, weil ausreichend viele Leute daran glauben.
Da hast du nicht ganz unrecht. Also es liegt schon daran, dass ausreichend Leute daran glauben, aber das liegt eben daran, dass Institutionen dahinter stehen, die halt sagen, dass dieses Geld etwas wert ist. Während bei Bitcoin eben die Datenbank dahinter steht. Natürlich gibt es jetzt Leute, die glauben, dass Bitcoin etwas wert ist. Auch im Wechsel zu anderen, also zu Realwährungen, wie dem Dollar oder dem Euro. Sonst gäbe es diese Exchanges nicht. Aber trotzdem denke ich, dass es keine Realwährung ist, weil halt diese Institution dahinter fehlt.
Jetzt muss ich aber spitzfindig werden, weil in Zeiten der Inflation, sagen wir mal Ende der 20er Jahre, da gab es auch diese bunten bedruckten Papierscheine, die von einer zentralen Institution rausgegeben wurden, die dahinter standen. Man konnte sich trotzdem nichts dafür kaufen, sondern für ein Päckchen Zigaretten oder eine Flasche Schnaps hat man was zu essen gekriegt und für die bunten bedruckten Papierscheine nicht.
Natürlich, das kann passieren. Wenn der Staat mystische Politik macht, dann kann das natürlich passieren. Bei Bitcoin kann das aber auch passieren, dass auf einmal die Leute der Meinung sind, akzeptiere ich nicht mehr und dann ist deine Bitcoin nichts mehr wert.
Ja klar, aber das macht es halt für mich genauso real oder irreal wie so genanntes echtes Geld.
Wie gesagt, für mich ist halt der große Unterschied, dass die Institution dahinter steht.
Aber was für ein Unterschied macht diese Institution? Also wenn ich euch beide zuzuhöre, als objektiver, völlig neutraler, unangenehmer Beobachter, habe ich den Eindruck, dass es schon dasselbe. Und der Unterschied, den du machst, ist, dass du sagst, die Leute, die an eine Realgeldwährung glauben, haben einfach quasi mehr Gewicht. Also du sagst, das ist das, was ich jetzt gerade verstehe.
Es ist ja in einem Gesetzestext festgeschrieben, welche Währung in einem Land als Zahlungsmittel gilt.
Aber wie viel, wenn es hart auf hart kommt, wie viel Wert ist denn dann ein Gesetzestext?
Wenn es hart auf hart kommt, dann ist der Gesetzestext natürlich nicht mehr viel Wert. Aber das ist halt Zusammenbruch des Marktes. Das sind schon Extremsituationen dann. Aber wie gesagt, ich würde halt die Unterscheidungen darin treffen, dass diese Institution trotzdem dahintersteht. Aber das natürlich, Bitcoin als virtuelle Währung, der kann dasselbe passieren, der kann das auch nicht passieren. Also die kann auch stabil bleiben. Also es gibt ja die sogenannten Goldbugs, die deswegen zum Beispiel Bitcoin kaufen, weil sie eben diesen zentralen Institutionen nicht vertrauen. Aber ich denke halt, dass ein Großteil der Bevölkerung eben nicht diese Ansicht ist.
Aber im Prinzip ist das ein interessantes Beispiel, weil hier die unterschiedlichen Perspektiven auf Finanzsysteme deutlich werden. Und ich würde sagen, das ist jetzt eher so Hackermentalität, gerne ein System schaffen zu wollen, das auch im Worst Case Szenario funktioniert.
Das ist natürlich richtig, also etwas zu bauen, zentrale Systeme haben immer das Problem der Angreifbarkeit der zentralen Institutionen. Wenn die wegbricht, dann fällt das System auseinander. Also der Goldstandard zum Beispiel, nicht dass ich ein Fan von Goldstandardwährungen bin, aber das gab sozusagen, bevor es die herausgebenden Institutionen gab, Gold und Silber als Währung. Und die haben auch ohne zentrale Institutionen funktioniert.
Da gab es auch zentrale Institutionen. Das waren dann Fürsten und Ähnliches, die gesagt haben, dass ihre Münzen in ihrer Region als Zahlungsmittel gelten.
Ja, in der Praxis angenommen wurde das Gold aber auch. Also teilweise einfach dann eingeschmolzen und weiterverarbeitet. Das war auch eine Entwicklung. Also es kam ja erst als sozusagen, es ging los mit Stückengold. Und irgendwann haben die Fürsten gesagt, na gut, ich präge jetzt hier mein Gesicht drauf als Garantie, dass das Gold auch gutes Gold ist und eine bestimmte Menge Gold. Der Wert war sozusagen nicht das Gesicht da drauf, sondern das Gesicht da drauf war nur eine Aussage darüber, so eine Art Versprechen, dass auch die Menge des Goldes stimmt. Ich würde es einfach nicht daran festmachen, dass nur per zentralen Institution rausgegebenes Geld echtes Geld ist und alles andere kein echtes Geld.
Die Frage ist halt, inwiefern man echtes Geld oder man diese reale und virtuelle Währung unterscheiden will. Also ich sage zum Beispiel auch nicht, dass Bitcoin kein Geld ist. Ich würde nur zumindest aktuell die Unterscheidung treffen, um es halt von diesen von Staaten gesteuerten Währungen oder von Institutionen gesteuerten Währungen zu unterscheiden, würde ich es trotzdem als virtuelle Währung bezeichnen. Genauso wie ich die Linden-Dollars, auch wenn da die die Linden-Labs hinterstehen, als virtuelle Währung bezeichnen würde. Oder ähnliche Währungen, die halt aktuell nur im Internet existieren, wo ich keinen Münz- oder Scheingeld am Schluss habe oder Giral-Konten oder Ähnliches.
Was Giral-Konten sind, würde das jetzt zu weit führen oder konntest du es kurz erklären?
Ein Girokonto.
Achso. Sag das doch, Herrgott nochmal.
Geld, das du auch nicht anfassen kannst, weil es nur in Rechnern digital existiert. Aber das ist echtes Geld, weil man kann zur Bank gehen und sich dafür Scheine geben lassen, ohne dass es hinterher anders heißt.
Ich bin ja so ein schlimmer Hippie. Ich versuche jetzt den Konten zu finden. Ist es denn aber schon so, dass du sagst, echtes Geld ist echtes Geld, aber es ist auch aufgrund eines Aktions. Weil diese Institutionen funktionieren müssen. Sondern eine Grundannahme, die man eigentlich auch nicht beweisen kann.
Also es gab zum Beispiel eine virtuelle Währung, die zu einer realen Währung wurde in Brasilien. Brasilien hatte eine sehr hohe Inflation. Und daraufhin wurde als letzter Plan, der dann funktioniert hat, eine virtuelle Währung eingeführt, in der alles ausgepreist wurde. Also es gab den, wie ist der, you are we, glaube ich. Man hatte halt eine Währung, die war in Woche 1, war halt die Milch 7 Credits wert und in Woche 2 14 Credits. Und diese virtuelle Währung, die Milch, war in Woche 1 eine virtuelle Währung, ist einheitwert und in Woche 2 dasselbe. Und das Ganze wurde dann so lange getrieben, bis die Bevölkerung wieder das Vertrauen drin hat, dass diese virtuelle Währung stabil ist. Und dann hat man es in eine Realwährung. Hat man auf einmal Geldnoten und Münzen wieder ausgeschüttet und hat quasi diese virtuelle Währung zu einer Realwährung umgewandelt. Und so hat man Brasilien aus der Inflation rausgeholt.
Ok, also real ist die Währung, wenn ausreichend viele Leute dran glauben. Ich glaube, das ist...
Da wird sich einverstanden. Um es nochmal auf den Punkt zu bringen, was genau müsste passieren, damit du sagst, Bitcoins ist eine reale Währung?
Ich kann beim Bäcker mein Brötchen damit kaufen.
So, jetzt hätten wir gerne den Typen, der wir haben das auf der Hinfahrt hier, kam das kurz auf, es gibt wohl angeblich in Kreuzberg einen Burgerladen, wo man mit Bitcoins Burger kaufen kann.
Den gibt es ja.
Irgendjemand hat das behauptet, der soll mal bitte hier anrufen. 0331 77 97 110. Falls jetzt gerade jemand in den Burgerladen steht und mit Bitcoins bezahlt, den würden wir gerne hier am Telefon haben. Sofort! Jetzt anrufen!
0331 77 97 110.
Also nicht wirklich, aber wir haben zu einem Punkt, wo wir sagen, so könnte man sich das vorstellen. Jetzt nochmal zu dem Mining zurück. Da sind es also Leute, die sagen, bzw. ihr habt das erklärt, Mining ist, wir signieren diese Transaktionen, diese verschiedenen, die es gibt, und dafür kriege ich als Belohnung neue Bitcoins. Das heißt, dann kann man reich werden, oder?
Ja, nicht mehr. Also wenn du das letztes Jahr gemacht hättest, wärst du jetzt schon stinkend reich, aber da wir alle letztes Jahr noch keine Ahnung davon hatten, sind wir alle nicht stinkend reich. Aber bis vor einem Monat oder zwei konnte man sich noch einen neuen PC und eine neue Grafikkarte damit finanzieren. Momentan deckt es noch mehr als die Stromkosten. Man kann sich vielleicht noch einen Burger damit kaufen, einmal die Woche.
Aber mehr ist sozusagen schon nicht mehr drin?
Nicht mehr so richtig, nein.
Okay, wie hat das vorher geklappt? Weil es da so einfach war?
Ja genau, die Schwierigkeit Bitcoin zu erzeugen steigt. Also je mehr Rechenleistung im Netz da ist, desto schwieriger wird es, eine Unterschrift zu finden. Und als es einfach noch nicht so viele Leute gemacht haben, war man einfach öfter mal dran und hat so einen Block abgekriegt.
Das heißt, man ist sozusagen schneller an die Belohnung rangekommen. Konnte man sich das so vorstellen?
Genau, man hat öfter mal das losgezogenen Hauptgewinn.
Zusätzlich ist es natürlich auch zu einer Wertsteigerung der Bitcoin gegenüber anderen Währungen gekommen in dem Zeitraum.
Aber das müsste ich eher Erfolgversprechender machen zu meinen, weil die 50 Bitcoin Gewinne mehr wert sind.
Naja, aber es sind halt auf einmal so viele Leute, dass die Schwierigkeit so stark angestiegen ist, dass es sich jetzt im Verhältnis zum Wechselkurs nicht mehr lohnt. Oder nur noch wenig lohnt. Nicht mehr so viel wie vorne mehr.
Wir haben jetzt hier jemand am Telefon, der behauptet, er würde das selber machen, und zwar den Rudolf Hallo. Du meinst Bitcoins, so heißt das ja am Fachsprech.
Ja, das mach ich.
Womit? Ok, du bist jetzt im Radio und müsstest jetzt ein bisschen, also nicht nur in Zahlen sprechen. Du hast also dir normalen PC hingestellt und eine bestimmte Grafikkarte dafür gekauft? Oder hattest du die schon? Und machst du das wie lange?
Ein paar Wochen.
Seit ein paar Wochen und hast schon wie viel damit verdient?
7 bis 8 Bitcoins.
Und hast du gemessen, wie viel Energie du verbraucht hast?
Ich denke der Energieverbrauch ist ungefähr die Hälfte davon von dem Wert.
Ok und dann hast du die Technik gekauft, das heißt du kriegst das aber auf jeden Fall nicht mehr mit rein?
Das wird sich zeigen, wie die Kurvenentwicklung ist. Wie weit Geld aus der jetzigen Wirtschaft hineinfließt.
Ok, das heißt du wirst es aber weiterhin tun in der Hoffnung, dass es irgendwie was dabei rumkommt? Oder tust du es auch aus Idealismus?
Ich schau mir natürlich die Strompreise an. Und was dabei rauskommt, klar, wenn es sich nicht mehr lohnt, höre ich damit auf.
Also in dem Moment...
Kommen wir zum Idealismus, das ist viel spannender. Ich hab mich in den letzten Monaten und so mal damit beschäftigt, wie unser Geldsystem Euro und so weiter aufgebaut ist. Nun, das ist ein... Dieses Geldsystem, das wir haben, pumpt unsere Arbeitskraft und unseren Besitz von unten nach oben in die Hände von Bankern und anderen reichen Leuten. Das kann man sehr leicht feststellen, wenn man ein bisschen tiefer eindringt in die Materie.
Ja, wir fragen uns gerade zu sagen, worauf du hinaus willst.
Bitcoin ist der absolute Gegenentwurf dazu. Bitcoin ist die Bedrohung für das Bankensystem, die Zeitstelle für die Unterhaltungsindustrie gewesen ist.
Okay, und wie kommst du zu diesem kühnen Schluss?
Na ja, das steckt in den Kinderschuhen, aber die Eigenschaften von Bitcoin sind...
Ich verstehe das sehr gut, aber der Punkt ist ja klar geworden. Bitcoin ist eine Bedrohung für das Bankensystem. Andreas, ist das auch einer der Pläne, die dahinterstecken?
Ich glaube, zumindest ein Teil der Leute, die das initiiert haben, sehen das ganz genauso. Und es ist ihre erklärte Mission, dieses Bankensystem mal ein bisschen in die Schranken zu weisen, schrägstrich vom Planeten zu entsorgen. Ob das so realistisch ist, da gibt es geteilte Meinungen. Auf jeden Fall ist das der Ansatz, der dahintersteckt. Keine zentrale Instanz mehr, keine zentrale Macht mehr.
Aber ich meine, es ist ja ganz schön, dieses Bitcoinsystem als Experiment, als Versuchsanstalt, eine Möglichkeit, um Dinge zu bezahlen. Aber gibt es da wirklich einen Hebel, wo so ein System tatsächlich das Bankensystem beeinflussen kann überhaupt?
Na ja, man darf nicht vergessen, dass ungefähr 30 Prozent der Weltwirtschaft Schattenwirtschaft sind. Das heißt, die sowieso schon mehr oder weniger an den offiziellen Kanälen vorbeifließen. Und die momentan noch irgendwie Geldwäsche, nennt man das glaube ich, durch dieses Bankensystem durchgeschleust werden, mehr oder weniger. Und da ist natürlich eine Menge Umsatz dahinter, da ist eine Menge Potenzial dahinter, die dafür sorgen könnten, dass so ein System abhebt.
Du meinst also, die bösen Leute, TM, sorgen dafür, dass es einfach zur Realität wird?
Das muss man glaube ich weiter aushören. Man könnte erstmal sagen, im Prinzip ja. Ob das jetzt die bösen Leute sind oder die guten Leute sind, hängt ein bisschen vom Standpunkt ab. Es gibt auch Leute, die sagen, naja, wenn man das mit den Drogen endlich mal legalisieren würde, dann gibt es nicht so viele böse Leute, die sich darum kümmern würden. Es gibt natürlich genauso die Anarchisten, die sagen, auch Staaten sind scheiße. Und irgendwie dann kann man das mit den Steuerzahlen auch gleich bleiben lassen. Es gibt andere, die sagen, ob ich jetzt irgendwie Bitcoin oder Euro steuern, sind Steuern. Das wird schon funktionieren. Die Bundesregierung hat ja auch gleich einen Vorschluss gemacht, ein neues Gesetz vorgelegt, dass also das Umtauschen von, ich benutze jetzt mal die Terminologie, realen Währungen gegen virtuelle Währungen auf jeden Fall anzeigepflichtig ist. Also wenn man jemanden Bitcoin verkauft, so der Gesetzesvorschlag, dann soll man ab sofort seine Identität feststellen müssen.
Dann wäre das ganze System so ein bisschen hinfällig, oder?
Na nicht unbedingt. Es hat ja nach wie vor interessante wirtschaftliche Aspekte. Teil des Experiments ist auch, was passiert, wenn man eine Währung nimmt, ohne Geldmengensteuerung. Also wo die Geldmenge von vornherein festgelegt ist und nicht jemand an der Stellschraube drehen kann.
Ok, was Geldmengensteuerung ist, dazu würde ich dann später gerne nochmal kommen. Jetzt haben wir Dennis am Start. Dennis ist auch ein so genannter Miner. Dennis, mehr oder weniger professionell betreibt, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe?
Ja, ich hab mich halt reingestürzt vor ein paar Wochen in das Thema und hab auch irgendwie mir ein paar Grafikkarten besorgt und bin auch am Minen, aber ich hab...
Wait, wait, wait, ein paar Grafikkarten?
Na ja, eine Handvoll.
Kannst du uns mal kurz beschreiben, wie dein Miningpool, also hast du eine Art Rechnerpark, dann irgendwie zu Hause rumzustellen, wie sieht das aus?
Nee, ich hab eigentlich nur zwei Rechner, aber in einem Rechner sind drei Karten, in dem anderen sind zwei Karten.
Okay, und die rechnen jetzt Tag und Nacht an diesem Bitcoin-Ding rum?
Die rechnen gerade Tag und Nacht rum, und jetzt wieder ein bisschen besser, weil gerade so schön kühl ist.
Jetzt haben wir gerade hier von Rudolf gehört, der hat irgendwie so seit ein paar Wochen dabei, macht irgendwie so acht Bitcoins im Monat. Wie viel ist bei dir schon rumgekommen?
Weil meine Hardware-Bestellung so lange gedauert hat, ist da noch nicht so viel rumgekommen, aber insgesamt habe ich schon, glaube ich, ca.
Und du hast jetzt wie viel Geld für das System erstmal auf den Tisch gelegt?
Vierstellig.
Vierstellig? Ok, so ein Bitcoin steht heute irgendwie bei was? 18 Dollar?
Ja, also ich hoffe, ich habe auch danach noch Nutzen für den Rechner. Ich hatte noch nie einen PC, ich bin ein Mac-Typ und ich habe jetzt endlich mal einen dicken PC.
Also auf jeden Fall kannst du dann irgendwie Battlefield gut spielen, falls du das betonen möchtest. Aber was hat dich denn dazu getrieben, einen vielstelligen Betrag dafür auszugeben? Ich meine, okay, vierstellig ist ein guter Rechner, kostet immer vierstellig, kann man sagen. Aber trotzdem, warum hast du jetzt sozusagen für Mining so viel Geld ausgegeben?
Na, weil erstens ich schon immer irgendwie mit diesen Kryptogramm-Sachen berechnen, irgendwie, oder Grafikkarten auch zum Rechnen einsetzen. Also es hat mir schon immer Spaß gemacht. Auch das gibt es diese Distributed Net, wo man Hashes berechnen muss, um zu zeigen, wie schnell irgendwie hier so ein RSA-Krypto geknackt wird. Da habe ich früher auch schon mitgemacht, irgendwann nicht mehr, weil es halt zu viel Strom gekostet hat. Man wird ja auch schlauer. Und bei den Bitcoins, weil man ja doch so einen gewissen Gegenwert kriegt, bin ich sozusagen wieder eingestiegen. Und an sich finde ich das Konzept mit dieser Währung, die halt instant irgendwie über Weisung stattfindet und so weiter, finde ich unterstützenswert.
Jetzt hast du, du betreibst das sozusagen schon richtig mit Plan, hast du mal gemessen, wie viel Strom das kostet, wenn du den Rechner so laufen lässt oder berechnet einfach?
Das kostet mich zu Hause ca. an Kilowattgrade die Stunde.
Und ich hab jetzt die Kilowattpreise nicht am Start.
20 Cent. Ich hab sogar Ökostrom, ganz schlimm, ich zahl so richtig viel für Strom. Also eigentlich, ich weiß noch nicht, wie lange ich den Strompreis wieder rauskriege, da müsste ich halt aufhören. Aber eigentlich ruf ich an, weil ich für mein Video werden wollte.
Dazu kommen wir gleich. Ich würde vor allem mal wissen, möglicherweise sitzen ja jetzt Leute vorm Radio und denken so, okay, ich würde das auch gerne mal ausprobieren. Was ist denn eigentlich tatsächlich nötig, um selber anfangen zu meinen? Also es ist ja so, wenn man sich diese Software runterlädt, dann kann man im Prinzip das Software auch sagen, bitte meine auch für mich.
Die aktuelle Software, also diese originale Bitcoin-Software, die auch alle haben, weil das sozusagen das verteilte Wissen ist, das ist ja da drin, die auch Sachen festlegen, die unterstützt ja seit, also mit der neuesten ja so, man kann mit der nicht mehr generieren, Bitcoins generieren. Das haben die abgeschaltet, weil die Software nur die CPU benutzt und das war einfach nicht effektiv. Das gibt es einfach in der aktuellen Software gar nicht mehr. Aber es gibt sogenannte Mining Tools und die meinen für einen und die sind dafür ausgelegt, Bitcoins zu suchen oder diese Hashes zu berechnen und zwar auf der Grafikkarte eigentlich hauptsächlich.
Kann man die sich einfach so runterladen und dann...
Ich könnte jetzt so ein paar Namen runterlassen, wo man suchen kann. Das eine heißt Phönix, das andere heißt POCLBM, dann gibt es einen GUI-Miner und dann gibt es noch die Abloh-Miner. Das sind so die vier größten, die mir jetzt einfallen.
Also GUI-Miner heißt, es gibt tatsächlich zu sagen, den kann ich mir runterladen. Da gibt es auch eine grafische Benutzeroberfläche und das funktioniert einfach.
Da gibt es eine grafische Oberfläche, dann trägt man seinen Pool ein, weil da muss man halt bei einem Pool mitmachen. Sono-Mining lohnt eigentlich nicht mehr, weil man bräuchte Monate, bis man selber so einen Blog findet. Deswegen macht man bei einem Pool mit und den kann man da eintragen und dann legen die los. Und diese Pools haben inzwischen auch schon so Web-Appies. Da kann man sich sogar schon die Menge an Bitcoins, die man berechnet hat, die kann man sich da sozusagen immer schon auslesen. Dann sieht man genau, wie viel Bitcoins man schon verdient hat.
Erklär doch erstmal noch genauer, was ein Pool eigentlich ist.
Na, wie gesagt, meiner selbst, wenn man für sich selber rechnet, man bräuchte Monate. Das könnte man sich jetzt statistisch ausrechnen mit der aktuellen Schwierigkeit, wie lange man da bräuchte und wie viele Mega-Hashes man so hat. Das würde einfach zu ewig dauern. Deswegen tun sich ganz viele Leute zusammen. Bei den großen Pools sind es bis zu 10.000 Leute und mehr, die halt diesen Hasch suchen. Und irgendeiner findet den dann. Und weil die das halt gemeinschaftlich gemacht haben, wird das durch alle aufgeteilt. Dann wird aber noch gemessen, manche haben ja mehr mitgemacht, die haben dickere Grafikkarten, manche haben ein bisschen weniger mitgemacht. Das wird so zu sagen proportional auf alle verteilt. Da gibt es auch noch so ein bisschen andere Verfahren, weil man da wohl irgendwie schummeln kann. Die teilen ein bisschen anders auf. Aber so im Großen und Ganzen ist diese proportionale Aufteilung das, was gang und gäbe ist.
Und dafür wolltest du jetzt Werbung machen, weil du selber so einen Pool aufgemacht hast?
Dafür wollte ich ein bisschen Werbung machen, weil ich habe einen Pool aufgemacht vor zwei Tagen mit drei Freunden. Der heißt btcmp.com, also www.btc.com. Wir sind noch ganz klein, da dauert es noch eine Weile, bis man einen Blog findet. Aber weil wir so klein sind, sind wir, wir können die Miner schneller mit neuer Arbeit versorgen. Was die großen Pools, wir sind da teilweise ein bisschen hinterher. Und man will ja nicht für einen Blog rechnen, der schon längst wieder durch den nächsten Blog überholt wurde. Deswegen haben die großen Pools eigentlich ein bisschen Nachteil. Und man will auch nicht, das kann Andreas vielleicht noch erklären, dass so ein Pool mehr als 50% des gesamten Hashing Powers hat. Weil dann könnte er sozusagen die Bitcoin-Macht übernehmen. Das will man eigentlich auch verhindern.
Das heißt, man will auch, ich muss mal kurz das umrutschen, man will jetzt sagen, viele kleine Pools lieber als einen großen.
Eigentlich schon, ja.
Was sagst du denn, was ist eine gute Poolgröße? Also wie viele Leute sollen da mitmachen?
Wie viele Leute kann man ja nicht sagen, aber von dem gesamten Hashing-Power würde ich sagen mal so 10%. Aber da gibt es welche, die erreichen schon 30% der gesamten Hashing-Power. Und das ist eigentlich ein bisschen zu viel.
Okay, um das mal anschaulich zu machen, wie viele Leute mit deinem Setup wären das? Also zwei Rechner mit fünf Grafikkarten insgesamt? Über einen Daumen gepeilt.
Das kann ich so schnell nicht rechnen. Ich glaube zur Zeit sind es 12 Terrahash, 10% davon sind 120, ne 1, 2 Terrahash. Also so schnell geht das nicht. 1000 Leute, sagen wir mal.
Okay, na gut, dann könnt ihr ein bisschen wachsen mit eurem Pool. Das letzte, was ich fragen will, ich habe gehört, es gibt nur eine bestimmte Sorte von Grafikkarten, die sich lohnen, wenn man das machen will. Welche ist das?
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen eine Firmwerbung. Es ist halt so, dass NVIDIA, die sind zwar für Renderfarben sehr gut, weil sie haben Floating Power für Rendering. Aber sie haben halt kein Integer, sind sie nicht so gut. Und bei Krypto braucht man halt Integer. Und da sind die AMD-Karten einfach viel, viel besser. Das heißt, die sind hauptsächlich genutzt. Und dann ist aber noch so, dass die neueste Serie von ist, ist die 6000er-Serie. Da hat AMD auch ein bisschen was umgestellt. Wahrscheinlich sind sie auch dann Richtung mehr Floating Power gegangen für die Rendering-Farben. Deswegen ist die 5000er-Serie von AMD eigentlich viel besser geeignet als die 6000er. Auch sind die da die Preise besser.
Also klar, alte Grafikkarten sind billiger. Aber wie krass ist der Unterschied von diesen Grafikkarten, von denen du jetzt gesprochen hast, bis zum nächsten Lohnwerteneinkauf? Also sind die wirklich so viel besser oder sind die so ein bisschen besser?
Im Vergleich zu welchen jetzt.
Was auch immer danach kommt. Du hast ja gerade gesagt, die 5000er-Reihe von AMD ist die beste.
Achso, der Unterschied zwischen der 5000er und der 6000er-Reihe ist, weiß nicht, würde ich jetzt mal sagen 10-20%, aber die 5000er-Reihe ist einfach billiger. Wenn nicht jetzt schon alle weggekauft werden auf Ebay und auf dem Markt. Also ich glaube die Preise sind inzwischen, haben sich angeglichen. Vielleicht stimmt die Aussage sozusagen jetzt auch gar nicht mehr. Aber der Unterschied zu Nvidia ist, würde ich fast sagen, 1 zu 8 oder so.
Und eine dicke CPU zu haben oder einen dicken Prozessor hilft dir überhaupt gar nichts?
Überhaupt gar nichts, nee. Also ich hab zu Hause drei Karten und die kleinste CPU, die ich kriegen konnte und die kann das locker abarbeiten. Die ist ja wie bei 2-3% Last. Also die CPU wird überhaupt gar nicht mehr benötigt.
Alles klar, so kann's gehen. Die arme CPU, ganz arbeitslos. Dennis, vielen Dank. Und viel Spaß beim Meinen.
Ich hab grad mal nachgeguckt. Die 5800er Serie, also die 58XX, die sind ausverkauft, die gibt's nicht mehr. Also da hab ich vor vier Wochen noch für 150 Euro so eine Karte geschossen und mittlerweile komplett vom Markt weg.
Das ist ja unglaublich. Das war doch das letzte Mal, ich überlege gerade, es gab schon mal eine Situation, wo irgendwas mit, also irgendwas auch so ZZT-Umfeld am Start war, wo dann irgendwelche Hardware weg war. War das das irgendwas mit GSM-Scannern oder sowas?
Das war ein Deckt-Karten, so PC-Card-Deck-Nodule, die es für 30 Euro oder so auf Ebay gab, bis dann die Software rauskam und dann waren sie spontan alle weg und haben es 300 gekostet.
Das war die Hardware, mit der man Decktelefone abhören konnte. Und die war dann relativ schnell weg vom Markt. Das ist ja alles unglaublich. Wir werden uns gleich in den nächsten Stunden noch ganz genau damit beschäftigen. Jetzt erst mal eine kurze Pause hier im Blue Moon. Die zwei Sprechstunden. Wir haben gerade, wenn du dieses Lied gehört habt, hat Andreas gesagt, wir müssten eigentlich mal eine Band gründen, die heißt Various Artists und das Album heißt dann Compilation und die Tracks heißen Track 1, Track 2, Track 3, Track 4. Der Typ heißt so ähnlich, Random, Hux Flux Deluxe heißt der Song und den hat der Niels hier angeschleppt.
Warum?
Was ist das? Wo hast du das her? Was soll das hier?
Aus dem bösen Internet. Steckt meiner 5 Sterne Liste drin und Chiptunes sind toll.
Ist Creative Commons Musik natürlich. Ich kann euch einfach runterladen. Ihr müsst einfach nur mal den Namen googeln. Ihr seid nämlich hier im Chaos Radio und da geht es heute um Bitcoins. Wir haben heute schon darüber gesprochen, was das ist und wie man das macht. Vor allem ist es eine virtuelle Währung, das heißt nicht, dass es die nicht gibt, aber das heißt, dass die vor allem im Netz existiert. Wir verwenden den Begriff mal dafür. Und die wird berechnet, dadurch, dass viele Leute sagen, okay, wir beobachten alle Transaktionen, die stattfinden. Und wenn du dem anderen ein Bitcoin gibst, dann schreiben das alle auf und dann ist das sozusagen, dadurch wird das real. Und das wird auch irgendwie berechnet und dadurch können Leute darum wieder Geld verdienen. Und es ist tatsächlich so, dass ich sagen muss, jetzt ist der Punkt gekommen, wo ich es nicht noch mal ganz von vorne erklären kann, ohne die ganze Sendung noch mal anzufangen. Das heißt, wenn ihr jetzt gerade einsteigt und euch das zu bunt wird, dann hört den Podcast von diesem Blumenohren. Den gibt es ungefähr so eine Stunde nach der Sendung auf fritz.de, wenn die Seite wieder funktioniert und dann gibt es das da. Dann könnt ihr das doch mal ganz von vorne anfangen. Wir waren jetzt dingeblieben beim Mining bzw. das haben wir abgeschlossen. Wir hatten vorhin kurz darüber gesprochen, dass es, also wir hatten den Unterschied zwischen virtueller und realer Währung gemacht und Niels, der Volkswirt, der heute hier ist, mit Andreas Bogk vom Chaos Computer Club, hat ja gesagt, ja, also wenn man damit Geld beim Bäcker, also wenn man mit dem virtuellen Geld beim Bäcker bezahlen kann, dann wird es realer. Er hat jetzt schon präzisiert, wenn man bei jedem Bäcker damit bezahlen kann. Und das muss er nämlich tun, denn es gibt in Berlin angeblich schon einen Laden, bei dem man mit Bitcoins, also der virtuellen Währung, tatsächlich bezahlen kann. Und angeblich ist jetzt aus diesem Laden jemand hier am Telefon. Hallo Jörg.
Jo, hallo, schönen guten Abend, Markus.
Guten Abend. Du hast, also was hast du?
Was habe ich? Worüber spricht jetzt der Room 77 in Berlin-Kreuzberg? Ich würde es mal auf Berlinerisch Burger-Kneipe nennen. Ein Burger-Restaurant mit Bar und wir akzeptieren Bitcoins seit ein paar Wochen und ich habe jetzt gerade hier angerufen, weil ein Freund von mir eine Nachricht geschickt hat, ruft doch mal da an, da geht es um das Thema.
Ok, dann erste Frage. Wie bist du dazu gekommen, dass du gedacht hast, ok, Bitcoins will ich hier auch für meine Burger akzeptieren?
Weil ich von Bitcoin als Zahlungsmittel sehr, sehr überzeugt bin, ganz einfach eine große Zukunft einräume, was natürlich noch viele, viele Hürden zu überwinden hat und eine dieser Hürden ist die Anwendbarkeit in einem Einzelhandel, in einem Supermarkt oder in einem Restaurant. Und da muss ja irgendjemand mal anfangen. Genau, außerdem finde ich das Thema sehr faszinierend. Also das ist ein Zahlungsvorgang, der Spaß macht. Anders als einer mit einer Kreditkarte, der im Übrigen genauso kompliziert ist und genauso lang dauert eigentlich fast. Ja, das waren so die Gründe, warum wir dachten, wir nehmen mal gern Bitcoins an. Außerdem erspart es unangenehme Gebühren und von der Sicherheit von Kreditkartensystemen muss ich jetzt, glaube ich, als Gastronom auf dem Chaosradio nicht anfangen zu referieren, aber von der Sicherheit von Bitcoin bin ich doch relativ überzeugt.
Aber darf ich trotzdem mal fragen, du unterstützt das System schon auch aus dem ideellen Gedanken, das heißt du würdest im Zweifel auch in Kauf nehmen, dass es möglicherweise mal einen Verlust gibt, aber du wolltest einfach mal diese Idee unterstützen?
Ja, Verlustsrisiko hält sich in Grenzen, weil ich kann ja den Bitcoin mehr oder weniger tagesaktuell, wenn ich will, stundenaktuell auch wieder in Dollars oder Euros eintraden, auf der einen Seite. Und auf der anderen Seite sind die Umsätze in Bitcoin, die wir machen, noch so gering, aber tatsächlich auch allein daher, von daher, dass das Risiko in Grenzen hält.
Aber kommen wir mal zum ganz praktischen Ansatz. Wie berechnest du den Preis eines Burgers? Also kostet er bei dir eine feste Bitcoin-Mengen oder guckst du in dem Moment, wo ich den Burger kaufe, nach wie viel der Bitcoin gerade in Euro wert ist und rechnest das dann in dem Moment um?
Nö, wir haben im Moment einen von mir willkürlich festgelegten Tauschwert, der gerade bei 15, 50 Euro pro Bitcoin liegt. Das ist ja günstig für jemanden, der seine Zeche in Bitcoin bezahlen will und das tun wir ja, weil eine gewisse ideelle Motivation dahintersteckt, das Ganze zu unterstützen, zu fördern, selber damit experimentieren zu wollen und wie gesagt, die Umsätze sich so in Grenzen halten, dass ich sagen kann, dafür nehme ich das auf den Ring, das muss ich jetzt im Moment in Kauf.
Was kostet denn gerade ein Burger da?
In Euros oder in Bitcoins? Es ist ganz ehrlich so, dass ich die Preise in Euro in den Kopf hab und eine Rechnung am Ende in Bitcoin umrechne, naja so ist das, also es ist einfach so, dass...
Okay, also du sagst einfach so 15, 50 ist Bitcoin wert und dann rechnest du aus irgendwie blablabla, das kostet halt jetzt 13, 20 Euro und dann ist das irgendwie 0, blablabla Bitcoins.
Genau.
Dann, was wir uns gefragt haben, als wir zum ersten Mal gehört haben, ist wie machst du das denn eigentlich, weil so eine Bitcoin Transaktion ist ja nicht instantan, sondern bevor die sozusagen real oder echt wird, muss die ja von anderen Teilnehmern im Netz bestätigt werden. Wie läuft der Bezahlvorgang bei euch ab?
Ich würde mal so sagen, ich warte auf gar keinen Fall, bis ich die sieben Bestätigungen aus dem Netz habe, bevor ich den Gast gehen lasse. Mir ist bewusst, was für ein unheimlich großer Aufwand das wäre, mich jetzt zu täuschen wegen 0, 8 oder 2, 8 Bitcoins und was man da für eine Umfassungsinfrastruktur aufbauen müsste. Hat auch noch keiner gesehen, dass so etwas passiert ist. Ich sage eigentlich, wenn ich die Bitcoinzahlen in meinem Client sehe oder sie in der Blockchain finden kann, auch noch unter den unbestätigten Transaktionen, dann ist der Zahlvorgang für mich erledigt. Es ist auch immer angekommen. Es war noch nie so, dass das dann irgendwie nach fünf Bestätigungen nicht real geworden wäre.
Wie ist es denn, welche Art und Weise passiert das? Bringen dann Leute ihre Laptops mit?
Es gibt zwei Devices, die da funktionieren. Du bringst ein Laptop mit, auf dem du einen Bitcoin Client laufen hast oder ein mobiles Endgerät mit einem Client. Da gibt es im Moment meines Wissens nur unter Android einen Client, mit dem man Point-of-Sale oder Face-to-Face bezahlen kann, wenn man einen Mt. Gox Account hat. Also das sind die ersten beiden Lösungen im Moment. Aber ich weiß, es brodelt überall und Leute trauben auf dem Boden an Clients.
Das heißt, man kommt da hin und irgendwie hängt eure Adresse aus? Das heißt, man kommt zu euch in den Laden und eure Bitcoin-Adresse hängt da aus? Oder organisierst du die für jeden bezahlvergangenen neu oder wie läuft das?
Was auf den Laden läuft, das läuft alles auf eine Adresse und da hängt ein Zettel an der Wand, da kann man so einen QR-Code abfotografieren, so ein Barcode. Viele Leute haben da Applikationen auf ihren Handys, die das direkt in die Zahladresse ummünzen. Da steht die Bitcoin-Adresse, falls jemand abtippen will, hat auch schon mal jemand gemacht. Und es steht eine sehr kurze Web-Adresse von dem Address Shortener. Die kann man kurz, wenn man ein mobiles Endgerät hat, einfach kurz in Web-Browser tippen und dann die Zahladresse daraus kopieren. Das sind die drei Möglichkeiten, die wir bislang gefunden haben, die am besten funktionieren.
Also, wenn ihr irgendwie schon Bitcoins am Start habt und die mal in Burger investieren wollt, könnt ihr, wie heißt der Laden?
Das ist der Room 77 in Kreuzberg, auf dem Gräfelkitz, Gräfestraße 77.
Könnt ihr mal gucken gehen. Da kann man schon mit Bitcoins betahlen.
Jetzt hab ich Hunger auf Burger.
So, tja Niels, siehst du mal, bald ist es ja alles Geld. Ein Burger kann man damit schon mit zahlen. Sehr schön. So, jetzt haben wir gleich noch einen weiteren Anruf, nämlich den Paul. Der hat eine ganz klassische Frage, soll man Bitcoins jetzt oder später verkaufen?
Genau.
Wie viele Bitcoins hast du denn?
Jetzt auf dem Konto oder insgesamt gemeint?
Insgesamt. Du?
Insgesamt hab ich seit sechs Wochen 75 Bitcoins gemeint. Wo hast du die her? Ja, ich hab mir einen Rechner gekauft. Also erstmal hab ich meinen benutzt, mit meiner ganz alten Grafikkarte, da hab ich halt vor sechs Wochen ziemlich wenig Profit rausgeschlagen, weil der Bitcoin Kurs noch sehr weit unten war, irgendwie bei 5 US Dollar pro Bitcoin. Und dann hat mich ein Gruppe hat auf die Idee gebracht, ein paar Grafikkarten einzukaufen, dann hab ich mir halt erst eine gekauft, dann eine zweite, dann vor drei Wochen nochmal drei Stück. Nein. Also für den Außenstehenden klingt ja schon ein bisschen verrückt, aber es hat sich jetzt schon fast rentiert. Also das heißt, in ein bis zwei Wochen habe ich dann einen Computer mit sechs Grafikkarten und einen Super-Mainboard for free.
Ja, aber nur, wenn du zum richtigen Zeitpunkt deine Bitcoins in sozusagen anderes Geld umwandelt. Darauf besitzt du jetzt auch deine Frage, wann ist ein guter Zeitpunkt zu verkaufen?
Genau.
Warum machst du es nicht einfach jetzt? Du hast jetzt 75, der Kurs steht bei 18 Dollar, das ist doch schon irgendwie ordentlich Geld.
Ja, genau. Ich habe halt diese 32 Bitcoins. Ich habe mir irgendwie gedacht, 10 behalte ich auf jeden Fall, immer. Das heißt, ich weiß nicht ob diese...
Warum nicht 23?
Das Ding ist halt, in den letzten Wochen war der Wert von 5 US-Dollar auf 8, auf 9, dann auf 15, auf 20 und dann bis 30, 6 US-Dollar. Also das sind so 20 Euro Profit-Kollegen gestiegen und das ist halt das Ding, das ist halt sehr schwankend, in der letzten Woche ist er so immer so auf 17, 18 geblieben und deswegen wollte ich halt fragen, ob man verkaufen sollte oder nicht oder was eure Meinung dazu ist.
Also ich habe dazu keine Meinung. Was sagt Andreas?
Disclaimer, please always do your own due diligence and consult your financial advisor. We own some Bitcoins. Never invest unless you can afford to lose your entire investment. Nachdem der Disclaimer durch ist, ja, es ist ein bisschen schwierig zu sagen. Tendenziell ist mein Bauchgefühl, dass der Wert erstmal eine Weile stabil bleibt. Also es sieht gerade so aus, als würde der Kurs ganz, ganz langsam fallen, aber es gibt momentan viele Leute, die eher ein Interesse daran haben, dass Bitcoin eine stabile Währung bleibt, als dass sie kurzfristig Gewinne realisieren wollen. Auf der anderen Seite kann es dir passieren, dass morgen irgendwie einer von den frühen Mainern durchdreht und mal anfängt 50.000 Bitcoins auf den Markt zu kloppen und dann wird der Kurs fallen. Es kann sein, dass irgendein technisches Problem an, das noch keiner gedacht hat, auftaucht und das Geld von heute auf morgen gar nichts mehr wert ist, das nicht auszuschließen. Es kann genauso sein, dass es irgendwie gut weiterläuft, die Nachfrage steigt und steigt und steigt und steigt und deine Bitcoins irgendwann 100 Euro wert sind. Also wahrscheinlich ist die beste Strategie in dem Fall das, was du schon tust, einen Teil zu behalten und einen Teil zu verkaufen.
Also jetzt hab ich doch eine Meinung. Ich würde jetzt nämlich so machen, ich würde so lange Bitcoins verkaufen, bis ich die Hardware Investition wieder drin hab und den Rest behalten.
Ja, das war auch meine erste Überlegung.
Und jetzt fragen wir noch den Volkswirten. Niels, was sagst du? Wie wäre dein Plan?
Also mein Plan wäre wohl auch genau das zu machen, was du machst, Markus. Ich bin jetzt auch kein Börsenspezialist oder sowas. Also es kann ja halt immer passieren, dass entweder einer der Early Adopters durchdreht oder dass ein Bug im System gefunden wird, was ja passieren kann, wodurch auf einmal der Bitcoin Preis fällt. Genauso kann es sein, dass es irgendwie in den Massenmedien auf einmal auftaucht. Also der Preis ist wohl gestiegen auf 30 Dollar, nachdem es in Fox News in den USA kam und auf ein Gadget und auf einmal ein Run auf die Bitcoins los war. Wenn was ähnliches passiert, kann der Preis natürlich wieder nach oben schießen. Aktuell scheint er ja relativ stabil zu sein. Ich würde auch mal denken, dass der erstmal stabil bleibt. Von daher würde ich halt immer gucken, dass ich schon ausgebe und jetzt nicht anfange zu sparen und zu sparen und zu hoffen, dass der irgendwann mal richtig steigt. Sondern würde halt gucken, dass ich erstmal die Hardware refinanziert kriege und meinen Strom refinanziert bekomme, den ich durch die Hardware verliere. Und dann kann ich immer noch sparen und mir überlegen, ob ich nicht gegebenenfalls auch Dinge in Bitcoin kaufe, anstatt in der Währung, wenn es gegebenenfalls günstiger ist, wie einen Burger oder Socken oder Server im Netz, wenn man sie braucht.
Und im schlimmsten Fall kann man dann immer noch Counter-Strike auf 12 Monitoren gleichzeitig zocken.
Genau, darf ich noch andere Fragen? Genau, weil ich habe ja schon gesagt, ich habe jetzt insgesamt sechs Grafikkarten. Eine brauche ich dann in längerer Zukunft selber für mich, für meinen Rechner. Und die fünf anderen brauche ich ja eigentlich nicht. Und weil ja auch schon angesprochen wurde, dass die jetzt halt bei Ebay so wunderbar weggehen, diese Grafikkarten, sollte man jetzt eigentlich schon aussteigen. Weil jetzt mache ich halt nur noch sechs Euro pro Tag. Quasi schon abzüglich der Stromkosten. Und ja, sollte man jetzt kurzerhand aussteigen, die Grafikkarten noch für gutes Geld verkaufen. Oder ja, also das ist halt, da bin ich so gespeitender Meinung.
Das ist nicht der blödeste Plan. Also die Difficulty ist ganz schön hochgegangen. So vor zwei Wochen kam da noch ein Bitcoin pro Tag und Grafikkarte raus. Und mittlerweile ist es ein Viertel am Tag. Und in noch mal ein paar Tagen wird es ein Achtel sein. Ich denke, in zwei oder drei Wochen ist einfach der Punkt erreicht, wo es den Strom nicht mehr wert ist. Der Plan, jetzt die Hälfte einer Grafikkarte zu verkaufen, ist eigentlich gar nicht so blöde.
Genau, und das verstehe ich auch mit der Difficulty nicht. Weil eigentlich nach meiner Einschätzung müsste die ja immer quasi pro Block ansteigen, ein bisschen und schwanken. Aber das sieht ja so aus, dass die echt immer irgendwie alle, ich weiß jetzt nicht den Zeitabstand, aber immer sprunghaft ansteigt. Und das finde ich ein bisschen komisch, weil es wird ja immer nur eine Anzahl von Bitcoins am Tag ausgeschüttet. Und vor einer Woche oder zwei Wochen hatte ich noch zwei Bitcoins am Tag gemacht und dann von einem Tag auf den anderen nur einen Bitcoin. Und diese Differenz muss ja irgendwo bleiben. Das ist ja nicht so, dass irgendein Riesen-Mining-Pool angefangen hat und die anderen sich abgreift.
Das Problem ist, dass du sozusagen, wenn du von Block zu Block die Schwierigkeit erhöhst, hast du ein Problem zu berechnen, wie hoch die Schwierigkeit denn jetzt sein muss. Also die Idee ist ja sozusagen, dass man im Schnitt alle zehn Minuten einen neuen Block haben will. Das kann man natürlich aber nicht vorschreiben, weil ob man jetzt einen Hasch findet oder nicht, hängt ja auch ein bisschen vom Glück ab. Deswegen muss man über einen längeren Zeitraum messen, wie die Leistung des Netzes gerade ist. Das heißt, man muss über einen längeren Zeitraum messen, wie viel Blocks pro Sekunde, pro Minute gefunden werden. Und dann kann man ausrechnen, auf welchen Wert man die Difficulty jetzt setzen muss. Das heißt, man darf es nicht so oft machen. Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu selten. Da würde ich zustimmen. Also einmal am Tag anpassen wäre, glaube ich, angemessen. Aber die Systemdesigner haben sich halt für alle 2000 Blocks, glaube ich, irgendwie so was entschieden.
2016 war im Chat gerade die Rede von...
2016.
Also ich hatte von 7200 Bitcoins am Tag gehört. Wird nur eine Bitcoin-Menge am Tag ausgeschüttet oder mehr? Und weniger? Also schwankt das?
Das sind momentan 50 pro Block. Und wie viele Blocks gefunden werden am Tag, das schwankt.
Also okay, gut.
Das ist abhängig vom Glück und abhängig von der Anzahl Leute, die drin sind.
Ich dachte, das wäre eine feste Blockzahl. Und dann hätte es keinen Sinn gemacht, wenn die Difficulty nicht angepasst wird.
Na man sagt, dass im Schnitt alle 10 Minuten ein Block gefunden wird.
Ja, dann bin ich eigentlich so weit durch.
Sehr schön. Paul, dann viel Spaß. Wenn du gar nicht mehr weißt, wohin mit deinen Bitcoins kannst du Burger essen gehen.
Bis dann.
Tschüss. So, Burger hatten wir schon irgendwie. Du hast gerade gesagt Socken. Was kann man denn eigentlich alles für Bitcoins kaufen?
Hauptsächlich Netzdienstleistungen. Das ist das Wichtigste, was es gibt. Serverplatz, Leute, die einem Webseiten machen, VPN-Verbindungen, solche Sachen gibt es viel. Die Socken hatte ich erwähnt, weil der Typ, der neben einem der Hauptprogrammierer der Software wohnt, der macht Alpaka-Socken. Das muss ganz tolle Wolle sein und ganz tolle Socken. Auf jeden Fall hat er den irgendwann relativ früh überzeugt, auch irgendwie auch seine Socken für Bitcoins zu verkaufen. Das ist also sozusagen das kanonische Beispiel für, man kann auch, es ist richtiges Geld, weil man kann richtige Sachen damit kaufen. Na was denn? Na Socken.
Socken und Burger. Okay, das ist im Großen und Ganzen schon das, was es war.
Na ja, es gibt dann noch die Untergrundgeschäfte, also der vor vier Wochen hat eine Webseite namens Silk Road große Schlagzeilen gemacht. Das ist so eine Art Ebay für Drogen. Da kann man also tatsächlich für Bitcoin Drogen kaufen.
Funktioniert das?
Äh, gewöhnlich gut unterrichtete Kreise behaupten ja.
Wo wir gleich zu einem nächsten spannenden Ding kommen, der Anonymität. Das ist ja eine Hoffnung, die damit verbunden wird eigentlich. Die grundlegende Idee, die hinter dem System steht, war ja zu sagen, wir wollen sowas Ähnliches wie Bargeld. Und die Eigenschaft von Bargeld ist ja tatsächlich, es ist anonym, weil diese Scheine sind zwar irgendwie einzeln und durchgehend nummeriert, aber das verfolgt ja keiner, wo die so lang wandern. Zumindest über einen großen Teil nicht. Jetzt haben wir hier aber ein System, was darauf basiert, dass sich alle Leute zu jeder Zeit ganz genau aufschreiben, wer welchen Bitcoin wohin schiebt. Das heißt, das ist ja eigentlich die totale Überwachung. Hat mit Anonymität überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Ja, das ist richtig. Anonymität war als Designkriterium offensichtlich nicht so wichtig, wie die Tatsache, dass es keine zentrale Instanz gibt. Ich hatte von erwähnt, in den 90ern gab es DigiCash, einen anderen Versuch, digitales Geld zu schaffen. Und da war es andersrum. Da gab es also eine zentrale Instanz. Dafür war das Geld wirklich anonym. Und wie du schon ganz richtig erkannt hast, die Tatsache, dass jeder alle Transaktionen sieht, macht natürlich auch das Nachvollziehen von Transaktionen leichter. Es ist also nicht anonym, es ist aber immerhin pseudonym. Das heißt, es steht nicht an jedem Konto ein Name dran. Man muss nicht im Postident-Verfahren eine neue Bitcoin-Identität aufmachen, sondern man kann einfach in seinem Client auf den Knopf drücken und haben neuestes Konto.
Obwohl unsere Politiker das wahrscheinlich gerne hätten.
Ja, das haben sie schon gefordert. Also der Gesetzesvorschlag ist in der Pipeline, kommt noch. Und pseudonym heißt erstmal, der Name steht nicht dran. Aber natürlich kann man, wenn man sieht, von wo nach wo Geld überwiesen wurde, Geldflüsse nachvollziehen. Also wenn du jetzt auf deine Webseite deine Bitcoin-Adresse schreibst und guckst, da Spenden entgegennimmst, dann kann man nachgucken, blogexplorer.com heißt die Seite, wie viel Geld da angekommen ist, von welchen Adressen das gekommen ist und an welche Adressen das Geld gegangen ist. Und da ist es natürlich auch möglich, durch Anwendungen fortschrittlicher Technologie, größere Geldströme auch über mehrere Konten hinweg zu verfolgen.
Und jetzt ist es aber so, ich kann mir beliebig viele Konten einrichten. Also sagen, ein Bitcoin-Konto ist im Prinzip nur für mich als User eine lange Ziffernfolge und davon kann ich mir in diesem kleinen Programm beliebig viele klicken. Gibt es da nicht eine Möglichkeit, dass ich die Bitcoins so hin und her schiebe, bis irgendjemand so verwirrt ist?
Ja, lustigerweise ist es ja alles genau dasselbe, was schon immer passiert. Also wenn wir wieder dabei sind, ja wir kaufen 100 Tonnen Kokain aus Kolumbien und bezahlen die, dann muss das Geld da ja irgendwie hin und von da muss es wieder irgendwie weg und irgendjemand muss sich am Ende des Tages die Burger davon kaufen. Und auch da funktioniert tatsächlich die Verfolgung so gut, da stehen Namen dran an den Konten, aber das sind dann Schattenfirmen und Tarnidentitäten, die gar nicht wirklich existieren, also auch mehr der Wiener Pseudonym und sowohl die Technik zur Verschleierung als auch die Technik zur Aufdeckung ist eigentlich total identisch zu dem, was bei Bitcoin passieren, ich sag jetzt einfach mal passieren wird, ich weiß nicht, ob es schon passiert, aber es ist total absehbar, dass es passieren wird. Das heißt, auf Seiten der Leute, die illegale Geldströme verfolgen, sind das Analysetechniken, wo man sagen kann, naja, ich guck mal hier und dann habe ich hier eine Verbindung, also hier habe ich einen Namen und da habe ich einen Namen, jetzt guck doch mal nach, wie viel Geld da lang geflossen ist. Also die Informatiker haben sich vielleicht schon mal mit Flüssen in Grafen beschäftigt, in gerichteten Grafen, das sind genau diese Algorithmen. Und die Gegenseite, die Geldwäscher, tut natürlich genau das. Wir machen ganz viele Konten auf und schieben das von A nach B und wieder von B nach A und alles durcheinander und hoffen, dass das irgendwie keiner sieht.
Jetzt hast du, als wir schonmal darüber gesprochen haben, meintest du, man könnte sowas wie ein Remixer machen, gibt es ja dieses Tor-Netzwerk, wo man Verbindungen genauso lang durcheinander lässt. Geht das irgendwie?
Naja, im Prinzip ist das so eine Geldwaschmaschine, dass man entweder ganz viele Adressen hat und das Geld von vielen Leuten zwischen den vielen Adressen hin und her schiebt und dann hinten wieder rausschiebt, das geht zum Beispiel. Oder dass man eine Adresse hat, wo alle drauf einzahlen und alle wieder Geld rauskriegen und dann muss man halt darauf achten, dass es nicht auffällt. Also wenn ich es rein hypothetisch angenommen, ich würde so einen Dienst betreiben und du würdest jetzt kommen mit deinen 73 Bitcoin 26 und ich nehme das entgegen, schiebe das ein bisschen durch die Gegend und tu dann auf der anderen Seite wieder 73 Bitcoin 26 raus, dann ist es ganz egal, was in der Mitte passiert, du wirst schon aufgrund der Zahl gefunden. Wenn man sagt, man macht das ein bisschen sinnvoller, man zerlegt also die 73 Bitcoin 26 in lauter Einheiten zu 10 Bitcoin und das macht man mit allen, da kann man nur noch gucken, wie viel Geld pro Sekunde rausgefallen ist. Das heißt, man muss dann auch die Geldflussrate mitteln und komplexen statistischen Modellen. Also das ist so ein Statistiker-Wettstreit. Wer hat die besten Statistiker?
Ich wollte gerade sagen, dass man immer wieder dieses klassische Wettrüsten hat. Leute fangen an, das zu verbergen, andere Leute fangen an, das nachzuverfolgen.
Naja, der zusätzliche Faktor, der auch noch reinkommt, ist, dass wenn du aus dem Bitcoinsystem austrittst, vielleicht dann dort unter Beobachtung stehst. Also wenn Andreas unter Beobachtung steht, weil man weiß, naja, der hat irgendwie was zu tun mit Dingen, die nicht sein sollen. Und dann schaut man sich die realen Geldflüsse, also quasi die Euro-Geldflüsse an, die Euro-Geldflüsse an, die zum Andreas gehen. Und das hat er vielleicht auch noch über Leute. Und dann kommt man auf die Bitcoin-Konten am Schluss.
Du meinst an den Stellen sozusagen, wo man Bitcoin in reales Geld umtauschen kann?
Also in dem Moment, wo es halt aus dem Bitcoin-Universum austritt, sind wieder die bekannten Verschleierungstechniken nur möglich.
Okay, da können wir gleich nochmal genauer drüber reden, wie man jetzt sagen, von dem Bitcoin zu richtigem Geld kommt. Weil über den Kurs, wir haben jetzt ganz schön die ganze Zeit schon geredet. Es war auch schon angesagt, dass es Umtauschbörsen gibt. Es gab in der letzten Zeit auch irgendwie zwei große Überfälle, kann man vielleicht sagen. Aber all das werden wir gleich nochmal genau klären und auch einen kleinen Zukunftsausblick wagen. Mit Markus Richter im Chaos Radio, der heute zu Besuch hat. Natürlich vom Chaos Computer Club in Gestalt von Andreas Bogk. Hallo und guten Abend nochmal. Und außerdem ist der Volkswirt Niels Kobschätzki da. Ja hallo, hallo, weil wir heute über Bitcoin sprechen. Eine virtuelle Währung. Was das heißt, haben wir schon geklärt. Wie das funktioniert auch. Wie man sich das Geld selber basteln kann, haben wir auch schon geklärt. Wie gesagt, man kann tatsächlich jetzt nur noch ganz kurz erklären. Das ist halt Währung, die vor allem im Netz stattfindet, die man sich selber zu Hause errechnen kann, wenn man sich einen Computer kauft, der richtig viele Grafikkarten hat und die ja vorbei an allen Geldinstituten funktioniert. Und ich wollte es nochmal genau fragen, wenn man diese Bitcoins hat, gibt es ja diese sogenannten Umtauschstellen. Wie genau funktioniert das da? Da gibt es Leute, die setzen sich mit einem Bauchladen auf die Straße und sagen, hier komm her mit deinen Bitcoins, ich geb dir richtiges Geld dafür.
Ja, ungefähr so funktioniert das ja.
Okay, und wie wird der Kurs festgelegt? Also woher wissen die, wie viel die mir dafür geben können?
Es ist der berühmte freie Markt. Also das funktioniert ein bisschen wie die Wiesenhandelsplätze auch funktionieren. Also so Börsen nennt man das üblicherweise. Das heißt, jemand kommt und sagt, ich hab hier Bitcoin und die würde ich gerne verkaufen und ich hätte gerne 15 Euro pro Stück. Dann kommt einer und sagt, ich will Bitcoin kaufen, aber ich biete dir nur 10 dafür. Dann gibt es ein sogenanntes Order Book. Das heißt, da wird eingetragen, wer wieviel bietet und wer wieviel bereit ist zu zahlen. Und wenn sich halt jemand findet, also ein Pärchen findet, das zusammenpasst, einen verkauft, dann wird diese Transaktion durchgeführt. Das heißt, diese Exchange-Webseiten tauschen gar nicht selber, sondern die vermitteln eigentlich bloß einen Tausch.
Okay, jetzt habt ihr ja vorhin schon ab und zu mal erklärt, wenn ein Early Adopter seine ganzen Bitcoins auf den Markt kippt, dann ist alles nichts mehr wert. Wie funktioniert das?
Na, muss ich überlegen. Man hat da die lange Liste von Leuten, die bereit sind, für Bitcoin Geld auszugeben. Der erste sagt, ich bin bereit, 14 Euro auszugeben. Der zweite sagt, ich bin bereit, 13 Euro auszugeben. Der dritte sagt, ich 10. Der nächste 5. Irgendjemand sagt, wenn sie 2 Cent kosten, dann kaufe ich auch noch welche. Und wenn jetzt jemand kommt und sozusagen dem ersten für 15 welche verkauft, dem nächsten für 12, dem dritten für 10 und dem letzten dann für 2 Cent, dann ist sozusagen der Kurs, was ja mehr oder weniger der Betrag der letzten Transaktionen ist, die passiert ist, nur noch 2 Cent.
Also der bedient quasi einfach alle Angebote und damit ist sozusagen der Markt leer und keiner will mehr Leute, will mehr Bitcoins kaufen und dann sind nur noch die ganzen niedrigen Angebote am Start. Genau. Und dann kommen die Spekulanten, die nutzen genau diesen Moment, um ganz viele Bitcoins zu kaufen und zu warten, bis es wieder viel mehr wert ist und dann...
Genau, also die Theorie ist, dass es gar nicht passieren kann, weil keiner so viel Bitcoin auf einmal hat, als dass es passieren könnte. Behaupten zumindest die Leute, dass es viele Leute gibt, die ein Interesse dran haben, die bloß auf eine Gelegenheit warten, billig an Bitcoins ranzukommen.
Das ist doch jetzt neulich auch gerade passiert, oder nicht?
Ja, allerdings durch einen Hack. Da wurde, Mount Gox ist eine von den größeren Exchange-Webseiten. Und die hatten da so ne kleine Sicherheitsschwankung und haben im Rahmen dieser Sicherheitsschwankung die Passwörter für ihre Accounts verloren. Und irgendjemand ist also rumgelaufen von Account zu Account und hat alle Bitcoins auf den Markt geworfen, die es gab.
Also wirklich alle die es gab oder alle die es gab? Also haben die wirklich alle Accounts aufgemacht, oder?
Das ist ein bisschen unklar. Ob es alle waren, ob es ein Teil der Accounts war, ich glaube es sah so ein bisschen aus, als wären alle. Weil es sind glaube ich 500.000 Bitcoins an dem Tag verkauft worden. Und das klingt schon, das ist wohl mehr als einer auf einmal besitzt. Wenn man den diversen Statistiken glauben kann, die Leute in den Foren so anstellen über die Verteilung des Besitzes an Bitcoins.
Und daraufhin ist sozusagen der ganze Markt zusammengebrochen?
Daraufhin ist der Markt zusammengebrochen, ja, weil der Kurs dann auf ein oder zwei Cent runtergegangen ist, weil wie gesagt alle Kaufgebote wurden erfüllt, alle Orders wurden erfüllt. Und dann wurde natürlich erstmal dieser Exchange geschlossen für eine Weile. Die Transaktionen wurden rückabgewickelt. Das ist vielleicht ein ganz spannender Punkt, weil eigentlich kann man eine Bitcoin Zahlung nicht rückabwickeln. Das ist nicht so wie bei einer Überweisung, wo man seine Bank anrufen kann, sagen kann, hey, da ist was schiefgelaufen. Und Lastschrift ist ein besseres Beispiel, weil da kommt es tatsächlich öfter vor, man sagt, hier bitte zurück buchen. Das geht nicht. Allerdings ist es so, dass diese Käufe und Verkäufe erst mal nur auf dieser Webseite passiert sind. Das heißt, man lädt Bitcoins auf die Webseite hoch oder man überweist Geld dahin. Dann hat man ein Guthaben auf der Webseite in Bitcoin oder Dollar. Dann kann man anfangen zu handeln. Dann kann man irgendwann anfangen, sich den Kram wieder auszahlen zu lassen. Und das ist halt noch nicht passiert. Also es ist ein bisschen passiert. Teilweise ist der Geld abgeflossen. So Leute sind reich geworden, die es nicht verdient haben, aber nicht besonders hohen Größenordnungen. Und viele dieser, in Anführungszeichen, unerwünschten Transaktionen, durch wie auch immer diese Passwörter gefunden hat, die wurden ruhig abgewickelt.
Das heißt also solange, aber genau, der andere Punkt ist also zu sagen, sobald so eine Transaktion im Bitcoinsystem selbst passiert ist, lässt sie sich ja nicht mehr rückgängig machen.
Genau. Das ist wirklich wie Bargeld.
Und da gab es auch auch einen Fall.
Ja, da gab es zumindest einen Fall, der bekannt geworden ist. Jemand hatte 26.000 Bitcoins gemeint, also auch jemand, der lange dabei war.
Holy shit!
Ja, schon bei dem derzeitigen Kurs der Gegenwert eines Eigenheims. Und da ist jemand in den Rechner eingebrochen, über ganz normal Trojaner, und hat die Wallet.dat geklaut. Also die Datei in Bitcoin kleint, wo der Schlüssel drinsteckt, mit dem man die Transaktionen unterschreiben kann. Und als er am nächsten Morgen aufwachte, war sein Konto leergeräumt, da war das Geld weg.
Das zu sagen, das ist letztendlich auch nicht mehr rückgängig. Das ist zu sagen, wie jemand, der in ein Haus einbricht und sozusagen 26.000 Euro in Bargeld klaut, das ist dann einfach dort. Wenn man den Typen selber nicht findet, ist es fort.
Genau, also man kann natürlich sehen, im ewigen Logfile, auf welches Konto das überwiesen wurde. Und wenn derjenige sich dumm anstellt, dann taucht irgendwann mal sein Name auf dem Zusammenhang mit diesem Geld. Aber wenn er halbwegs schlau ist, wird das nicht passieren.
Das heißt also, so anonym ist es dann doch schon. Man kann zwar die Transaktionen nachverfolgen, aber es ist trotzdem nicht so einfach, Netznetzen einzelnen Typen zu finden.
Das ist nicht unbedingt einfach, nein.
Wie heißt das dann, würde ich dir empfehlen, wenn man Bitcoins hat, dann soll man das eigentlich auf einem dedizierten eigenen Rechner machen? Weil eigentlich hat ja jeder Rechner Sicherheitslücken.
Ja, das hängt immer so ein bisschen von den Mengen ab, die man durch die Gegend bewegt. Wenn man da so eine 1, 2 Bitcoins hat, das ist als hätte man 10 oder 20 Euro in die Tasche. Wenn man die verliert, gut, ist ärgerlich, aber es ist kein Beinbruch. Aber wenn man irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 20.000 Bitcoins, also sowas wie 300.000 Euro, ein bisschen weniger, 250 sind es schon. Wenn man das rumzulegen hat, und das einfach auf einem ganz normalen PC, mit dem man sich dann abends seine Pornos anguckt, das ist...
Das macht doch niemand.
Das ist schon ein purer Leichensinn.
Ja, da hat es dann jemand erwischt. Jetzt haben wir noch 20 Minuten, dann ist die Sendung schon vorbei. Ich würde gerne mal jetzt die Frage stellen, ob man sich dargestellt hat, dass ja bei Bitcoin diese Hoffnung verbunden ist, dass es etwas ganz Neues ist. Den Eindruck, den ich habe, ist aber eigentlich, dass das eine nette Spielerei ist. Mit der man auch reich werden kann, aber das kann man ja mit Börsenspielen auch. Aber eigentlich ist das nur so eine Art Test. Wie seht ihr das? Hat Bitcoin eine Zukunft im Sinne von, dass wir genau dieses System in 15, 20, 30 Jahren immer noch haben werden oder ist das jetzt sozusagen der erste Schritt in der Richtung sozusagen virtuelle Währung und da kommt möglicherweise dann aber nochmal was anderes, Neues, Besseres? Oder ist Bitcoin quasi das Facebook des virtuellen Geldes?
Ähm, ist Facebook nicht auch gerade am Eingehen? Aber naja, mein Eindruck ist der, dass also ich hab Bitcoin von einem Jahr ungefähr schon wahrgenommen und ich hab mir gedacht, das wird nie erfolgreich. Das wird nie was. Das ist viel zu abgedreht. Das verstehen die Leute nicht. Und bin eigentlich auch überrascht, wie erfolgreich es schon geworden ist. Mein Bauchgefühl ist, also irgendwas stimmt da noch nicht. Irgendwie wird es gegen die Wand laufen. Das ist ein glorioses Experiment. Und mindestens werden wir viel davon lernen. Also ich würde nicht meine Hand dafür ins Feuer legen, dass Bitcoin in einem Jahr noch existiert oder zwei. Aber nachdem meine letzte Vorhersage über, wie Bitcoin sich entwickeln wird, falsch war, kann ich auch nicht ausschließen, es ist total erfolgreich sein wird. Und 20 Jahre weiter begleiten wird.
Ich denke auch nicht, dass man es ausschließen kann. Ich denke aber eher, dass Bitcoin, also dass genau das Bitcoin eher erstmal Nischensystem bleiben wird. Also das ist begrenzt. Leute, diese begrenzte Anzahl kann natürlich sechsstellig sein, siebenstellig. Es gibt eine Menge Internetnutzer, also weltweit. Aber dass es trotzdem bei einem Nischensystem bleibt, weil einem Großteil der Leute einfach mal Dezentralität und diese Pseudonymität relativ egal ist und die Leute lieber ihre Waren in echter Währung shoppen. Also nicht in echter, sondern in ihrer eigenen Landeswährung. Also Sie, Amazon, die gerade Großwerbung damit machen, dass man jetzt ihren Kindle in Euro, ihre Bücher in Euro kaufen kann, statt in Dollar wie vorher. Also die Leute wollen einfach in ihrer eigenen Mehrung einkaufen. Es ist natürlich auch eine Frage, wie sich die Transaktionskosten entwickeln. Es gibt Firmen, die gezeigt haben, dass man sehr kleine Transaktionspreise, sagen wir mal 79 Cent, einen Euro, schon mit einer Kreditkarte abwickeln kann. Wenn das weiter runtergeht, ist auch an dem Punkt Bitcoin nicht unbedingt stärker aufgestellt. Es ist aber halt für diese Nische, die jetzt an, also die an das Experiment glaubt oder die halt dem System TM nicht vertraut. Für die ist das natürlich eine feine Sache. Von der kryptographischen Seite habe ich jetzt nicht so die Ahnung, um jetzt sagen zu können, das müsste besser laufen oder man müsste dieses komplette System anders aufbauen oder dass man da noch was anderes findet. Aber es ist sicherlich ein schickes Experiment, um mal anzuschauen, was dann da so passiert.
Jetzt gab es vor zwei Tagen die Meldung, dass es ein neues Geldwäschegesetz gibt, glaube ich. Ich glaube 1000 Euro ist dann die Grenze, alles, was da drüber ist, das muss dann gemeldet werden. Glaubt ihr, es gibt überhaupt eine Chance für anonymes Bezahlen im Internet? Anonymes Bezahlen von Kleinstbeträgen im Netz?
Ich denke, das ist ein bisschen so wie mit der Versuch, Alkohol zu verbieten. Das hat ja auch nur sehr eingeschränkt funktioniert, oder überhaupt Drogen zu verbieten, also Anonymität im Internet zu verbieten. Dazu gehört ja Bezahlen im Internet, das ist ja ein Teilaspekt von Anonymität im Internet. Es existiert ein extrem großer Bedarf dafür. Man kann versuchen, das zu illegalisieren, das wird es aber nicht unterbinden.
Okay, aber was man jetzt vermuten könnte ist, dass sich da, was Niels gerade sagte, irgendwie da so Kleinstbeträge mit Kreditkarten, da gibt es schon Anbieter, die können das, dass sich das einfach weiter durchsetzen können, also durchsetzen wird im Sinne von, es ist für die größeren Teil der Leute bequemer.
Ja, vielleicht ist es ein Grund. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie mit den Transaktionskosten so weit runterkommen werden, weil man bei Kreditkarten immer das Betrugsproblem hat. Das sind echt enorme Volumen, die sie da in Fraud investieren. Es gibt ein paar technische Gründe, die dagegen sprechen, dass das Bitcoin-System so wie es gerade existiert, sich weiter verbreiten wird. Teilweise gibt es Lösungsansätze, teilweise nicht. Das Problem ist, dass man ja dieses ewige Lockfile hat und dass man alle Transaktionen sieht. Das heißt, man hat auch eine Datei auf der Platte, wo alle Transaktionen ever drin sind. Und die wird natürlich immer größer. Es gibt erste Ansätze, das Problem zu lösen, dem man sagt, man hebt sich halt nicht die gesamte ewige Liste auf, sondern man glaubt den Kontostand von letzter Woche, merkt sich den und schreibt bloß inkrementell die Änderungen weg und regelmäßig schmeißt man halt den alten Kram raus. Das andere Problem ist, dass ja alle Transaktionen in diesem Peer-to-Peer-System ge-broadcasted werden. Das heißt, jeder schickt alle Transaktionen, die passieren an alle. Und wenn man sich jetzt überlegt, wie viele Millionen Leute, wie viele zigtausende Transaktionen pro Sekunde über alte Zahlungssysteme abwickeln, heißt es auch, dass es ein enormer Traffic ist. Also man braucht eine enorme Bandbreite, wenn man sich mal vorstellt, dass 5 oder 10 Millionen Leute oder 100 Millionen Leute Bitcoin benutzen. Und dafür gibt es halt noch keine wirkliche Lösung. Und das sind so die technischen Herausforderungen, wo Bitcoin am Erfolg nochmal scheitern könnte.
Was denn jetzt hat Sophia gerade noch angerufen und die meint, hallo und guten Abend?
Ja, ich hab mir so ein bisschen Gedanken gemacht, wie das vielleicht auch so in der Zukunft des Bitcoins aussehen könnte. Und ja, also wie ich mir das vorstelle, wäre halt einfach, dass Bitcoin auch einfach erstmal ein Türöffner ist für alle möglichen anderen Sachen, die man sich halt vorstellen könnte. Also es gibt da halt ja auch so Systeme wie Ripple, was ja im Prinzip, wo halt im Prinzip insgesamt kein Geld drunter ist, sondern sich nur gegensätzlich die Leute Kredit geben. Aber das sind halt Freunde voneinander. Oder... Was ist das?
Hat das einer von euch auf dem Schirm hier? Nee, was ist das?
auch halbwegs dezentrales System, wo man sich und sein soziales Umfeld reinmachen kann und denen sagen kann, ja, denen würde ich so und so viel Kredit geben. Dann kann man das machen. Und das Interessante ist, dass dadurch die Kredite auch von dem einen zum anderen wandern können. Also, dass man...
Also eine Kreditweitergabe über verschiedene Funktionen. Und du meinst also, dass Bitcoin dazu führen kann, dass einfach andere alternative Bezahlsysteme jetzt an den Start kommen?
Genau.
Seht ihr das auch so, dass es ein Angebot gibt für viele weitere Neue? Gibt es überhaupt gerade schon Ideen, das weiter zu entwickeln? Oder ist es bis bei Bitcoins gerade erst mal Schluss?
Na, das Bitcoinsystem selber ist, ja wie gesagt, Skalierbarkeit ist da gerade das große Zauberwort. Es gibt andere Ansätze für digitales Geld. Es gibt eine Website, da gibt es bestimmt zwei Dutzend historische und gerade laufende Versuche, digitales Geld einzuführen, alternative Währungssysteme einzuführen. Es gibt ja auch schon immer Versuche, Alternativwährungen zu etablieren. Also auf Tauschbasis. Dann kommt man mit einem Tausch-Umrechnungssystem. Gab es nicht auch in Kreuzberg mal so eine Alternativwährung zum Beispiel?
Ich weiß nicht, in Dresden werden jedes Jahr immer zu der Bundesrepublik Neustadt, glaube ich, immer eigenes Geld ausgegeben.
Im Irak gab es eine Alternativwährung, die jahrelang zur offiziellen Währung im Herlief, vor allen Dingen im kurdischen Bereich.
Okay, Niels, ich habe noch mal die Frage. Du hast ja den Unterschied gemacht zwischen realer und virtueller Währung, und dabei dein Kriterium Institutionen. Das heißt ja momentan noch Staaten. Siehst du, dass das auch in Zukunft das Maß der Dinge sein wird? Weil das eine der interessanten Dinge an Bitcoin ist, dass es einfach eine Nicht-Staatenwährung ist. Es gibt ja in Science-Fiction-Szenarien häufiger, dass Leute, dass dann Firmengeld, dass so ein Firmengeld sprang, also dass eine Firma eine Währung ausgibt. Glaubst du, dass es in Zukunft immer noch Staatengeld geben wird? Oder wird es möglicherweise andere Währungsausgeber geben können? Also Facebook-Credit zum Beispiel wäre so ein Beispiel.
Das hat sehr weit gegriffen.
Wir spekulieren zum Schluss nochmal.
Die Sache ist ja die, dass ich ja immer noch etwas hab, was sich öffentliche Güter nennt. Also sowas wie Parks, Umwelt oder ähnliches. Und das ist ja was zum Beispiel über Steuern mitfinanziert wird. Also dass meine Straße nach Möglichkeit keine Schlaglöcher hat. Da kommt der Staat nicht unbedingt hinterher. Oder dass nicht jeder mit einer Benzinschleuder die Luft zu pestet. Von daher bräuchte man diese öffentlichen Güter, die ja jeder konsumiert und die nur so pseudomäßig eingesch... also uneingeschränkt verfügbar sind, aber trotzdem jeder konsumiert, die das kontrollieren bzw. das bezahlen. Und wäre halt die Frage, ob sich da andere Institutionen bilden, die das halt realisieren können. Sagen wir mal Großkonzerne, wenn wir irgendwie den Umstieg haben, dass Großkonzerne auf einmal extra territoriale Gebiete erschließen können, also wo sie unabhängig sind von den Staaten und dort dafür aufkommen, dass es bei ihnen die Wiesen schön grün sind und alles und Leute dort leben wollen, dann könnte es natürlich staatenlose Währungen geben. Es ist die Frage allerdings, ob eine entsprechende Entwicklung stattfinden wird.
Aber Währung ist für dich immer auch mit einem Gebiet verknüpft, was es geben muss, muss ich sagen. Ich empfinde ja zum Beispiel, es gibt ja zum Beispiel, was man auch als Währung benutzen könnte, es gibt ja diese Online-Shops zum Beispiel, oder ich überlege gerade, bei PC-Spielen wird tatsächlich immer noch mit realem Geld immer bezahlt.
Da kann man mit Bitcoin einsetzen.
Nee, aber du hast ja quasi schon zu sagen, es gibt ja diese Points, das sind ja Punkte quasi. Das ist ja schon eine Art virtuelle Währung, weil man sich das weiter denkt. Also wenn jetzt irgendwie ein Supermarkt angefangen würde, irgendwie iTunes oder Playstation oder Xbox Punkte zu akzeptieren, ist sowas.
Ja, das passiert ja teilweise. Also diese berühmten Meilen, wenn man Vielflieger ist, mit denen kann man ja auch schon Dinge kaufen. Und dann, wenn man ein Hotel einsteigt, kriegt man dann auch Meilen, wo man sich gar nicht bewegt dabei. Also vieles davon existiert ja partiell schon in manchen Märkten. Und sicherlich wird das weitergehen. In einer Welt, in der Nationalstaaten an Bedeutung verlieren gegenüber Konzernen, das ist natürlich auch naheliegend, dass dann auch die Konzerne anfangen, Währung rauszugeben. Und genau das ist natürlich der Punkt, wo man mit einem Gegeneinsatz, der halt nicht zentralisiert auf eine große Organisation ist, möglicherweise auch den Lauf der Weltgeschichte anders steuern kann. Also weiß nicht, ob wir mit Franchise-Staaten so glücklich werden.
Ich empfehle Snowcrush zu lesen, von Niels Stevenson. Hieß er, ein Nationalist-Buch, wo so ein Gesellschaftssystem auch beschrieben wird. Ich möchte jetzt ganz zum Schluss nochmal kurz die Frage stellen, nach der Geschichte dahinter. Also du hast ja gerade erzählt, irgendwie der Nachbar von einem der Programmierer verkauft Socken. Das sind Bitcoins. Weiß man jetzt genau, wer das gemacht hat? Also ich habe mal versucht nachzulesen. Es gibt irgendwie so, es gibt einen ominösen Typen mit einem japanisch klingenden Namen, der irgendwie so mal ein Paper geschrieben haben soll, was darauf basiert. Also kann man irgendwo diese Geschichte nachlesen? Gibt es da was?
Ja, man kann sich auf bitcoin.org das Paper runterladen. Also tatsächlich hat er das Paper geschrieben, während er die Software geschrieben hat, also sozusagen eigentlich seine Software dokumentiert. Und nein, man weiß nicht, wer das ist.
Wer legt denn dann diese Schwierigkeiten fest? Das wird ja anscheinend angepasst über Zeitintervalle?
Ja, das ist in der Software festgeschrieben. Also es ist mehr oder weniger schon eine Konvention, die alle Leute, die jetzt drin dran beteiligt sind, einhalten. Das heißt alle verwenden dieselbe Software. Bestimmte Regeln sind in diese Software einprogrammiert. Also so ganz komplett dezentral ist es nicht. Also es gibt schon noch Möglichkeiten das System zu beeinflussen über die Software, die das tut, weil die genau solche Regeln festlegt. Wie zum Beispiel, wie viel Bitcoins rausgegeben werden.
Wer gibt dir dann raus diese Software? Also wo kommt die denn her? Die muss ja irgendwo...
Da gibt es ein Entwicklerteam und die kann man runterladen. Also sozusagen in Anführungszeichen ganz normale Internet-Open-Source-Software.
Und wer das Entwicklerteam ist, weiß man aber auch nicht so genau.
Doch, die sind relativ bekannt. Einer von denen hat auch schon eine Einladung zur CIA bekommen. Er soll doch mal vortragen, was das ist und wie das funktioniert. Der Termin müsste bald sein.
Und da geht er auch hin, weiß man das?
Da geht er hin, ja.
Das ist ja schon auf dem Weg außer Landes. Verstehe, verstehe. Gut. Haben wir da noch was vergessen? Oder sind wir dann durch mit den Bitcoins?
Ich glaube, wir sind so gut wie fast durch. Namecoin hat noch jemand im Chat erwähnt. Namecoin ist quasi der Versuch, die Bitcoin Software dazu zu verwenden, ein dezentrales Namensauflösungssystem fürs Internet zu bauen. Also DNS, was schon, wenn du www.fritz.de eingibst in dein Browser, läuft der Browser ja zur deutschen Registry für DE und fragt, wer denn Fritz ist. Und dann kriegt er einen Verweis auf den Names, aber der sagt fritz.de ist da hinten. Dann läuft man da und sagt, wer ist denn für die Webseite zuständig, kriegt eine Adresse raus. Und dieses Namensauflösungssystem ist halt auch ein zentrales System. Es ist ein Route-Name-Server. Und Namecoin ist jetzt also der Versuch, die Dezentralität von Bitcoins, das technische System zu nutzen, um ein verteiltes Namensystem zu bauen. Wobei der Erste, der einen Namen will, sagt, ich will jetzt den Namen, dann wird das in die ewige Liste eingetragen. Und dann kann den auch nie wieder jemand wegnehmen. Ohne zentrale Instanz.
Oh, okay. Und ist das schon ein Erfolgversprechen? Das ist dann aber ein Parallelsystem, das existiert.
Genau, das ist mit der Software für die Bitcoins sehr eng verwandt. Es funktioniert sehr, sehr ähnlich, aber es hat seine eigene Blockchain, also seine eigene Kette.
Aber ich muss sagen, es ist aber auch ein Parallelsystem zum herkömmlichen DNS-System, das jetzt noch existiert.
Genau, weil dezentral und nicht zentral.
Stimmt, in der Tat. Verrücktes Backofenzeug, also wenn ihr euch die guten, guten, guten Domains sichern wollt. Dann solltet ihr jetzt gleich auf Namecoins umsteigen. Gut, dann haben wir für die Bitcoins den Podcast zu dieser Sendung. Gibt es, wie gesagt, in einer Stunde auf fritz.de. Im Verlauf des nächsten Tages dann auch auf chaosradio.de. Fragen dazu könnt ihr gerne noch stellen im Blog zum Chaosradio unter chaosradio.de. Wer hätte das gedacht? Außerdem will doch bestimmt noch mal die Gelegenheit ergriffen werden, um Werbung zu machen für dieses kleine Ding, was da stattfindet im Sommer. Da bist du doch auch irgendwie mit verbandet, oder?
Ja, genau. Da gibt es nämlich das Chaos Communication Camp vom 10. bis 14. August in Finofort. Und wir werden fünf Tage zelten und hacken und Club-Mate trinken und schnelles Internet haben und in der Sonne liegen und es in den Bauch pinseln.
Und da darf jeder hinkommen?
Ja.
Da kann man sich dann irgendwie ein Ticket bei euch holen?
Genau, Ticket gibt es auf der Webseite. Einfach mal bei Events.cde gucken.
Dein persönliches Programmhighlight, hast du schon eins?
Äh, nee, noch nicht.
Okay, dann ist jetzt der bei uns raus. Kann man euch jetzt nicht vorhersagen. Gut, dann vielen Dank. Andreas Bogk vom Chaos Computer Club im Chaos Radio. Vielen Dank fürs Dabeisein. Niels Kobschätzki, der Volkswirt. Vielen Dank fürs Dabeisein. Ich verabschiede mich an dieser Stelle. Das Chaos Radio ist also vorbei. Hiernach kommt mit Henrik Schröder der Nightflight, wo es Punk-Musik geben wird, wie ich den guten Mann kenne. Ich wünsche euch dabei viel Spaß. Mir bleibt nur noch eins zu sagen. Macht immer schon eure Backups und lasst euch nicht überwachen.